hey you guys know me every other word
out of my mouth must be civil war or
something like that and people are in
the chat saying tim civil war pool
well i certainly think we're in a cold
civil war
maybe it's even hot it's just too early
for us to realize it on a grand scale
but things are absolutely getting crazy
we have a couple big stories i mean one
of which is this black lives matter
activist who was arrested you need to
turn that volume down what are you doing
here i got you homie i get one you get
one this black lives matter activist was
bailed out by blm by black lives matter
in louisville louisville after he was
arrested over the attempted
assassination of a jewish democrat now
they're saying he's mentally unwell
other people have pointed out it's been
reported that he was actually advocating
for a black nationalist organization
called um oh what was the name of it i'm
forgetting the name is the is the uh
armed forces of some uh extremist
organization no it was like it was it
was a similar group to the black hebrew
israelites and so when this stuff
happens and you're getting the you know
attempted assassination of politicians
it's coming right after adam kinzinger
said
you know he believes that it's possible
civil war is going to could start and if
it does you will see targeted
assassination so i want to get into this
and we do have a lot of stories coming
out now we got the national guard
deployed in new mexico to be teachers
and things like that we've got the
trucker convoy obviously that's a that's
up in canada but there's talk of an
american convoy we've got cancel culture
we've got uh you know
similar issues around this we've got to
in florida they've just passed a bill to
ban abortion after 15 weeks which of
course is generating a lot of
controversy joining us to discuss this
in depth is the author of the next civil
war stephen marsh hey pleasure to be
here do you want to quickly introduce
yourself
i'm a writer i'm a canadian
i wrote this wonderful book um yeah and
i uh i sort of think that next civil war
is very much a real possibility for the
united states in the near future i think
you wrote um what did you write for the
guardian the next civil war that was an
excerpt from the book i mean the book
got excerpted in the guardian and the
washington post and foreign policy uh
sort of the more technical aspects got
uh got excerpted in foreign policy and
so yeah like it's it's been around like
this this is and it was based on an
article i wrote in 2018 in canada uh
about the possibility of civil war um
which i
was talking about then in 2018 and sort
of yeah i'm a you know i'm a stray cat
journalist i go around and write for
whoever leaves that a little plate of
milk for me so we i think we've actually
on this show discussed your article i
know i talked about on one of my uh my
other channels oh yeah and i think
there's like a core that we completely
agree on but then there's like a
divergent world view we have based on
you know the different political parties
which i think will be a really
interesting conversation so what's the
core we agree on
the uh
i think it's you know people are forming
at the time we read the article it was
easy for me to pull out the excerpt
you mentioned something about
people are sort of tribalizing they're
focusing more on you know their own
in-groups and things like that and
that's causing this like outward spread
you've talked about things like cancel
culture yeah specific scenarios and
stuff so i'm like i'm reading your
articles and i'm like i think we we
agree on those things but then there's
certain specific points in politics i
think we'll have disagreements sure yeah
but but that doesn't uh uh you know
whether or not we agree on something
like the trucker convoy it doesn't
change the fact that the core of what's
happening civil war conflict the
escalation we agree yeah i mean i
definitely think an a a non-partisan
observer can look at the united states i
mean it's a textbook case of a country
headed for civil war it's not really a
question of your political affiliation
it's really a question of deep
structures that
you know anyone can see so it's those
are not i i don't really think of that
as a partisan issue right i agree and
and what i keep saying is you know to a
lot of people who maybe are you know one
side or the other it doesn't matter if
you think you're right what matters is
both sides think they're right well i
mean there's that old expression would
you rather be married or right right and
like in america a lot of people would
rather be right than married you know
that's that's where you're at now i mean
i should say like i don't really think
of myself as a partisan in the united
states because i'm a canadian so my
like when i talk about canada we can
definitely talk about canada but
you know what we're seeing in canada is
essentially a proxy conflict for the
hyper partisanship in the united states
and you know i think of myself like i i
think when you think of canada you think
left but honestly as i've crossed the
united states writing this book and as
i've interviewed the experts
i'm not part of these tribes right like
i'm outside of all of these tribes so
it's it's not really that we have a
difference in
tribalism so much as i have a different
perspective because i'm a different
citizen of a different country well so
we'll get into everything yeah we'll get
into all this stuff plus we have a bunch
of other stories too when we get into
specifics on but also hanging out is
daniel turner yes great to be back
daniel turner your favorite energy
expert powerthefuture.com and because of
the coming civil war i live on a very
large farm
far far away from civilization so i'm
fascinated with this conversation so
good to be with you we have incredible
chicken conversations behind the scenes
this seems like a pretty functioning
farm to me i mean you got fresh eggs i
see the incubator downstairs i mean like
you're one step away from jeremy
clarkson running a like i i own a farm
show i mean we
we grew some vegetables in our garden
but you know actually how'd they go uh
we grew all tomatoes at once because we
were newbies and didn't know what we
were doing and then we had like 15
minutes at a time oh that's when you
need to can them you need to get the you
need to get the sauces going we we went
berry picking because there's um what
are they called wine berries everywhere
this is a beautiful part of the united
states of america i gotta say this
little corner of west virginia and
maryland i mean in the summer time
there's wine berries there are chinese
raspberry and they're everywhere and
people pull over their cars on the side
of the road and pluck some and just eat
them but we'll get into all yeah as well
they're good am i here to talk about
agriculture yes
how do you write wine berries on a scale
from one to ten
good to see you man the pleasure to be
here forward to hearing about this uh so
this documentation you've come across uh
i'm not gonna waste any time ian
crossland catch you guys soon i am
stoked for this conversation with our
northern neighbor canadians are always
incredibly nice guests and very nice
people in general and it's been a really
interesting conversation before the show
it's gonna be a great one so glad you're
here before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support
all of our work support our journalists
support this show as a member you'll get
access to exclusive members only
segments from the tim cast irl podcast
now truth be told because of how we're
going to be handling today's episode
it'll be a little different normally we
focus on like topical news i don't think
we're going to have a members segment
because i think we're going to try and
hit every possible point we can in one
big conversation whereas normally we try
and like create like a special segment
for for members so i think we might we
just might go a little bit longer than
usual but let it be open and free to the
public for everybody just watch but that
being said we do have a massive library
of members only videos you definitely
want to check those out because you're
helping make sure this business can
continue to operate if uh in the face of
cancelled culture and all that stuff
this is how is how it all operates and
uh you keep our journalists employed
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's just jump in to
the first article we have here from
january 4th by a man named steven marsh
the next u.s civil war is already here
we just refuse to see it
i saw this it's uh it's tagged by the
guardian the far right
and as i was reading it you know there
are some things in it that i was like
okay i don't know if i agree with that i
think you talk about uh voter
suppression and things like that that's
one of the issues but i was but i was as
i was getting into it and talking about
how we've got these uh you know look a
potential political assassination
attempt that that's not uh not
necessarily like a left right thing with
this black lives matter activist it it
just shows that there's
extremism emerging in this country but
of course you also have serious things
over the past several years like
charlottesville where there's classes in
the street yes so let's just start from
the beginning though um you wrote a book
the next civil war
this article the next u.s civil war is
already here
i don't write the headlines you didn't
write that yeah so do you think that it
is likely is it is it your opinion or is
it a a journalist's assessment well the
book is really
based on the best available models like
that's what that's that's how i i did it
i tried to keep myself out of it as much
as possible um so you know the leading
experts um that uh foreign policy did a
survey like their their number was a 67
percent chance of a civil war um that
that also coincides with polls about
average americans think how likely they
think a civil war is so
you know i feel with this stuff you
don't need to exaggerate it's so scary
anyway that like what i wanted to do in
the book is be as precise as possible
right and use the best available
evidence um that i could so
you know yeah there's there's a process
underway in the the united states is a
textbook case of a country ahead of a
civil war on a number of fronts and it's
not one thing it's actually what they
call a complex cascading system so
it's things feeding into each other so
on one hand it's political illegitimacy
on the other hand it's effects of
climate change on the other hand it's
the levels of inequality which which are
at unprecedented levels uh you know
literally levels have that haven't been
seen since 1776 and all of these things
contribute to each other and and factor
into each other and that's why the
united states is kind of in a unique
position because you know all these
things are happening in the rest of the
world as well but it's the way that they
feed into each other that creates such a
dangerousness are there any species are
there specific things that you found
factored across multiple potentials that
you just kept showing up like this is
one of these things that it seems to be
in all these scenarios well the big i
mean there are a few ones that are big
like i don't i don't really separate
them out because i do think they feed
into each other but like the decline of
faith of institutions so the fact that
only 20 of americans believe their
electoral system is fair um you know
that's that's right that's that's a
condition that's just right for civil
war um the fact that 33 of americans
think that it's okay to use violence if
your side loses and that's
equal democrat republican like it's i
think well they're very similar one's 32
percent one's 36 percent right so
that is a huge factor um so
that's a big one
i'm curious how much of that is honest
and what i mean by that well i you know
i these models are all of different
strengths so like all i can do is tell
you what this is for sure for sure so i
think um you know just leaping off from
there we have the story about uh the
black lives matter activists right
accused uh allegedly shooting this um
this this democrat certainly there have
been instances where far-right and
right-wing groups are given to violence
but if you look at um
institutional support
when it comes to say black lives matter
in 2020 you get kamala harris soliciting
donations to bail out rioters
you have a black lives matter activist
who's arrested for the attempted
assassination of a politician and black
lives matter fronts a hundred thousand
dollars to bail him out
you don't have the same kind of thing on
the right
well um
let me answer that question in two ways
okay so the first thing is that the
process that um civil war experts talk
about and this happens all over the
world happens in chile it happened
in other places of war it's called
complementary radicalization so what you
have is
left-wing groups or right-wing groups
taking extremist positions and this
causes people on the other side to get
more radical
so that's that's a that's an area that
transcends
you know uh
partisanship like that's le that's now
that's a process that's underway yeah
where
as things get more extreme on the left
they get more extreme on the right that
causes the left to get more extreme that
then causes the right to get more
extreme right and so that's that's a
very toxic uh process that is extremely
hard to escape from now the other thing
i would say is that when i talk to
you know this is just let me just give
you this perspective you can take it or
leave it you know it might be useful to
you it might not be but when i talk to
like members of secret services of other
countries and they're thinking about
what a collapsing america looks like
they're not really afraid of the left
because
the left is inherently self-defeating
it is
much less organized than the right like
it and it and it's also
it's much less effective as a as a group
so like when you look at a group like
the oath keepers
they're enormou they they are they have
it together like they they have it they
are to have it together in a way whereas
when you look at left-wing institutions
like the women's march after the trump
inauguration it had you know somewhere
between half a million and a million
people
at its opening rally it explode it
imploded on in internecine politics
almost instantly and like the term woke
institution basically doesn't exist
because they eat themselves right like
so
all i would say is like both both these
processes are underway but i would say
that when when i talked to experts on
civil war from other countries and
people who are worried about the
stability of the united states it was
definitely
far-right extremists that were their
primary words what about the
institutionalization well hold on i
wanted to address this real quick yes
i don't think you're wrong but the way i
say it the way i see it is
the right i would describe as sharp the
left i would describe as blunt black
lives matter was able to raise you know
what tens of millions of dollars
for
relatively nebulous causes but that
attracted thousands of people to riot in
the streets over
2020. the damage caused was severe and
it did result in a lot of death but it
was very very widespread so typically
what we see a lot of especially um at
the start of you know donald trump's run
for pr the presidency i was actually on
the ground at a lot of these these trump
rallies you see uh blunt level terrorism
it never exceeded the the uh it was
political violence
terrorism to me is a technical term that
would not apply to that i mean in terms
in terms of this book like like
terrorism is very specific
like it has very specific
consequences and it's very specific i'm
not to say that we're not dealing with
political violence well let's just
understand the violence yeah so
political violence to me is a better
term so uh the political violence you'd
see on the left would be
rampant but low scale so there'd be a
lot of instances of someone getting
punched in the face or someone getting
pushed in the street or people running
around and knocking over garbage cans it
was incessant
it was never rising to the point where
you know
for a lot of it people were losing their
lives until i think the riots that but
we we've seen right
to me like as an outsider
like what who's right and who's wrong
and and the nature of the violence is
less important to me than the stability
of the system right like as a canadian
up north like wanting america to hold on
so that we can trade with you like what
i'm concerned with is the stability of
the system so you know
like when defund the police happened
right
maybe the worst political idea of
i mean it's a it's a high bar now i'm on
board with it but yeah keep it going we
love it for electoral purposes keep
supporting right
but you know also completely non-doable
and
in support
well they did in one place they couldn't
get it achieved anywhere else they got
it in minnesota and then 200 i think 260
departments had their budgets slashed
and then they came back right not all of
them i mean but but a lot of them did
come back yeah or chaz right capitol
hill autonomous zone which is probably
the the number one example of left-wing
of left-wing
resistance to federal authority i mean
that is a subject in the book but it's
really very little
it has very little impact when compared
to the militias
what is the one of lamisha's like so i
can name a ton of things like jazz the
chess chop there was there was that was
in seattle then you also had the
portland attempts you had the occupation
in in minneapolis
well the oath keeper list i mean they
have well obviously january 6th i mean
would be at the top of the list um but
you know as a very highly destabilizing
action but you know like the other thing
about the right is that they're they
understand the importance of
institutions in a way that the left is
not this is you understand i'm i'm not
judging no i'm just saying i'm just
saying no no i agree like like they like
when you look at the oath keeper list
like with it came out with that 40 000
names like they'd infiltrated very
deeply into police departments into uh
you know school boards like when i
talked to michael german who's like a
who was an undercover agent for with the
fbi and far right movements he was like
once they discovered i had no tattoos
they were like you're never going to
talk to anyone rough ever again we're
going to run you on a school board like
that's that's what we're going to do so
what i'm what i mean to say yeah just
because i want to make sure i can let
daniel come in is um
i think the the one of the reasons
there's a lot of people who who don't
think that the far right elements
uh many people on the right don't think
that there's a big threat from them
because they don't see it a lot right
the way to describe it is it's sharp
versus the left's blunt you know the the
i think
you're right when you say that they know
the importance of institutions the right
talks about losing institutional control
at the time
what the left doesn't understand uh what
they have is numbers people will go out
in the street and march and smash things
but a day later where are those where
those actions yes and they have no
policy
like they have like they have like their
policy ideas are unfeasible well that's
generally true i mean i think i think
like that's true of the left and the
right well what's happening in america
is it's entering a post-policy phase the
government can i mean this is the other
thing we talked about you asked like
what are the major causes like one is
this decline in institutions but it's
also that the united the government is
america's essentially becoming
ungovernable right like like it it know
what like biden has spent 11 months
getting diplomats
in place right it it's called the us
government is constantly threatening to
renege on its debt i mean that is that's
playing russian roulette with all of
this all of this prosperity the federal
reserve is ungoverned they've never
audited it there there there is a huge
number of ungovernable well you know to
me like as a canadian when you look at
the big build back better bill or
whatever it's called um that's a budget
that's a wednesday in a mature democracy
like
you just pass a budget and that's it in
the united states those are those basic
functions of government are increasingly
impossible or extremely difficult
and that leads naturally to a politics
of rage right where it's like because
you can't ever enact policy
whether you're left or right you become
so
everything becomes aesthetic everything
becomes a everything becomes an
aesthetic artistic gesture of your own
anger and your own beliefs in a in a
concept
that is that transcends
essentially
you know real actions real government
actions and that's that's a huge to me
that's maybe the number one factor yeah
people think they're supposed to be
creating policy they should be stripping
away bad policy right now here when i
hear american politicians like think
tanks and so on say like we have to do
this with the tax rate we have to
yeah no no no i'm saying no i'm saying
pop your mind
oh sorry sorry sir
um like when i hear them talking about
policy like parental leave or something
it's like you guys can't pass you can
barely pass a budget why are you even
having these conversations about
parental leave or whatever like
you you could you're you're you're in a
system that is increasingly
non-functional and and the thing is like
you know one of the most important
models in the book is that like that is
only going to increase dude i was
watching canadian parliament go nuts and
people were heckling basically i was
like in an american court you would be
thrown out if you heckled well have you
ever seen the british one that's like
it's like it's like a hold over from
british like even the speaker was like
you guys cut it out like they're trying
to like it's 21st century where adults
don't scream over each other
they come from like british parliament
where they're trying to interrupt the
guy speaking they're trying to disrupt
them and british parliament is one of
the great entertainments
of all time what are they called the
questions session well the friday
sections it's wonderful the the question
period like the the the point of a
parliamentary system as opposed to the
american system is that there's a
concept of the loyal opposition so your
job is to attack
the government
whether you think they're right or not
and that's just when they're like yeah
so
and that and that creates that creates
an environment where i d where you know
every leader
has to be humiliated like like every
leader every politician no everyone's
just a servant right and and that's
that's that's just a completely
different condition in the united states
yeah i don't know i don't know if we
lost the point you were trying to make
before daniel no i i i think it's it's
it's worth bringing back not just
because it's my point but i think it
touches on what you were saying of
institutions
um
so you mentioned uh oath keepers and you
were also talking about black lives
matter in the sense of institutional
uh dysfunction and how i love that you
said the right sees institutions is
inherently necessary
well that's or or
um well as opportunities for advancement
of their own program okay
like that's
both sides now are
destroying the institution absolutely
but one of the things that i'm curious
about is when you take a group that is i
think incredibly polemic and that does
cause a lot of division which is
something like black lives matter
institutionally
they're they're golden right you have
bank of america who writes them checks
you have the nba you have major
institutions that support what i think
is a purely political entity but it is
held up to this level and i think that
causes a lot of rage because
the oath keepers regardless of what you
think of them would bank of america ever
write them a check they probably
couldn't even get a loan at bank of
america so i think there's institutions
have chosen sides and i think that's
leading to a great greater level of the
of the division well the money in
american politics is really confusing
because
like for example like you saw the new
york times article about dark money that
came out like a week ago like i mean
that to me is the most appalling story
in american politics that i know of
where
the money that 2.4 billion dollars that
decided the 2020 election no one knows
where it came from some of it came from
foreign sources for sure but nobody
knows where it came from now 1.5 billion
came went to the democrats and 900 000
went to the republicans
so 900 million sorry 900 million yeah um
did i say a billion billion 700 thousand
went to the government right uh my
canadian small-time politics stuff but
uh
that's
and and so you you and then there's the
other fact that like while republicans
are pro-business and so on like 70 of
american gdp comes from biden voting
counties that seems to me like one of
the key facts that's going to determine
the future of this country
in civil war or out of it or at the end
of it and so like i think there's
that i i will acknowledge i i find it
confusing like where where money goes to
where is coming from like where what it
is supporting and what it wants i find
it confusing that certain political
causes are are objectively
uh acceptance that accepted to receive
money or to be on the board or write a
check to and others are not because
those causes are aligning more and more
well the cox brothers
i mean the top brothers
no they they do no they do absolutely
but i mean
but you're you're never going to go to a
a uh
a knicks game and at the halftime show
have them give a 500 000 check to this
political cause but you will see it for
something like black lives matter you
will see it for something like planned
parenthood you will see so the the the
philanthropy of politics i think has
become very very divisive because
certain philanthropy philanthropic
groups are are tolerable and others and
real quick yeah
it's only one koch brother the other
right sure right but just you know i
thought that was right well they i think
they also stopped giving money to
political causes too like a few years
ago like they're there's i think they
give it to like uh like reform things
they just decided they're not doing
partisan
anymore there are a lot of wealthy
individuals that are willing to fund
either side you know peter thiel's well
that's it
structure i mean this is the deposit the
point is really not who
is giving money to who the point is like
all this money is destroying the system
and making it inherently unstable and
there's also the politicization of
everything which is where you have
homophobic chicken and you have
uh lgbtq positive cookies
like you know like they're where like
literally every aspect of life
is is politicized that also is classic
prelude to civil war but this this is an
interesting point because um potentially
what was the start of the culture award
i know you asked gamergate you're
familiar
uh this is this was a lot of people who
identified themselves as left
libertarian on the political spectrum
being angered that everything was
becoming political because you had these
uh quote unquote news organizations
video game you know news and video game
companies increasingly putting very
specific ideologies in their games and
people were upset with that right so
they would agree with you like why are
we politicizing everything please don't
bring me into gamergate man i mean my
life
is hard i was playing heroes of the
storm last night on blizzard and i was
like if i type f the ccp am i going to
get banned off of blizzard i didn't test
it but i was wondering well there are
certain things that that youtube banned
but uh you know to to the point about um
you know politicizing everything yeah
video games did used to have a lot of
politics in them but it was more of like
background acceptable american views
when they started becoming very
different like um you know
at core like marxist
having some kind of like marxist tinge
to a lot of them what do you mean by
marxist so
i i will say in america that word has a
meaning that i mean i mean understand in
the true sense of marxist ideology of
oppressed versus oppressor
well so like okay i would i mean
like
mark to me marxism is
there's lots of oppressed versus
oppressor ideologies but marxism to me
is strictly a class-based struggle all
other all other structures are
invalidated no but that that was a key
point i mean i think around occupy wall
street we had the very much yeah
class-based narrative of the one percent
well exactly occupy wall street to me is
cloud is that's that's a mark's a
struggle but video games almost can't be
i mean he rejects is that he he rejects
any aesthetic category well so are you
familiar with the origins of critical
race theory yeah but that's not i mean
to me that's
that's not marxism i mean you know
i think it i think it has come it has
come to mean something in this country
that i i just don't recognize in my own
like in my own readings of marxism in my
own readings of
i've certainly con like to me that
that's a that's an identity politics
formulation which is a completely
separate thing well when it comes to
roblox you want to talk about video
games enslaving people in a class-based
system that's what it is totally off
subject okay so critical race theory
specifically kimberly crenshaw wrote
that marx didn't understand american
racial politics and that the idea of a
press versus oppressor can't just be
class-based when race is inherently tied
to class right uh yeah but i mean that's
inherently a rejection of marxism
right like i mean right like that like
mark says like in the jewish question he
says
you know there are there there are no
there aren't effect no ethnicities all
there is is class so i i think so to me
like you know like th this whole reading
of martial it's a semantic issue though
is what i was saying i guess so but like
it does seem to me pretty important that
like the this because because marxism
conjured so much evil in the world
right like because it because it
conjured so many totalitarian regimes
like to call something marxist to me is
like
that i mean that's kind of the ultimate
insult because it was ultimately
so evil right and
for like that's not what that's not what
applies to these other forms let me let
me bring you there so uh i went down to
occupy wall street on like day three
and right you were
right so you know i ended up streaming
and stuff but uh it started out with
conservatives libertarians liberals and
leftists all in one place saying we very
much oppose the bailouts the corruption
in the system the revolving door
policies in the first week there was so
much talk about these big banks got
bailed out the the guy who works for the
pharmaceutical companies gets a job with
the fda the guy from the the war machine
halliburton becomes the vice president
it's a revolving door sure but within
about two weeks
critical race theory took over
and all of a sudden you couldn't speak
at their assemblies if you were a white
man and if you wanted to speak or i
should say you're at the bottom of the
list on their progressive stack right so
what started out as
in
essentially marxist the the class based
oppression yeah quickly turned into a
bunch of intersectionalists critical
race theorists coming in and saying no
no you guys don't understand
race is actually the core component and
then all of a sudden the narrative there
shifted the libertarians and
conservatives left and that this was one
of the start the starting points at
least in the culture war that i've
experienced yeah well this is what i'm
talking about when i'm talking about
self-defeating left-wing politics like
this is what i was talking about
like like
like what is required from the left now
more than ever in a complete sense is
solidarity and it is completely
incapable of providing that even on the
most basic levels
right and that's why to me like
because my my book what my book is about
is about collapsing systems right and
and how systems collapse and like what
is causing the collapse of systems and
the left is actually too weak
to cause a collapse of the system
because it eats itself in five minutes
that's why occupy wall street went
nowhere but that's technically not true
well occupy wall street resulted in a
massive shift of wealth from for-profit
to credit unions and it resulted in i
think the democratic party pulled their
money out of bank of america and moved
it to amalgamated which is a union
operated oh yeah so uh oh there how much
was that
uh the dnc's funds i don't know i can't
remember
tens of millions maybe
probably tens of millions i mean like
i'm talking about the united states of
america but it's it's a big uh you know
you plant the seed of a cultural shift
and that and that matters
so when i look at occupy wall street and
i see the rise of
what was effectively a form of if it was
overtly critical race theory it then
makes its way into something bigger into
media it expands that was the first
experience i had with it it was kind of
a crazy experience to see how racist
they were i mean overtly separating
people into different racial categories
to make them vote on policy
was insane do you think you would
qualify as someone who was comp like the
process of complementary radicalization
would apply to you oh yeah absolutely
yeah that's interesting so uh so how do
you like
how do you
negotiate that i'm curious there's like
do you like because you know the way
that they think about it the way that
the experts that i talk to think about
it is like a an inverse pendulum so like
as a pendulum swings
you know it tends to the center but in
american politics it tends
the energy sends it to more extreme
forms right we're not seeing the same
level of
extremism on the right as we are on the
left oh i disagree i mean i would have
to disagree with you there
like i mean
you see there's there's all kinds of
right-wing extremism i mean there's and
and and the other thing about extremism
on the right is also way better armed
well let's let's let's let's talk about
some examples
january 6th we got that's a big one for
sure there you go
but what else the oath keepers list 40
000 people what did they do what have
they done
well january 6th i mean but look january
6 you had uh
800 people
well i mean certainly like they're
relatively different okay well the the
extreme right in the united states is of
course really hard to figure out um you
know the way i think of it is as a
um like a smorgasbord of ideologies some
that are completely incompatible and
some that are so there's it's true of
the left too oh the left is totally
chaotic yeah it's all right like it's
like like i i
i mean for my own sake i think we can
just dismiss the left as a as a force
right because in america because it is
so disorganized and it eats itself right
um
so what you see on the right is like
there are sovereign citizens there are
three percenters there are uh you know
uh oath keepers there there are
sagebrush rebels there are
uh you know um second amendment
absolutists there are tax evasion people
there are ten tax women's people so
what have they done well of the
political murders of every year which
are amount to like about 70 on average
since 2015 uh i think the the number
don't quote me because it's in the it's
in the book and i don't have it on my
fingertips but i think it's like 72
percent are far right and like seven
percent are far left and the middle is
like various so like i would say like
when i talk to the experts um the the
fear of political violence is is much
clearer from the right and that's why i
said i feel like the fire is more sharp
right when they do take action yeah it's
extreme
well you know we're also dealing i think
we should acknowledge this because we
are all trying to stay human beings here
is that we're dealing with a lot of
people who are on the line between
mental illness and political affiliation
we're dealing with a lot of people who
are
criminal
who are just simply criminals and use
politics as a cover for their violence
and
like that has to be acknowledged too
right and that this and that this
political radicalization gives them
cover for
mental illness and for and for their
violence right so those things all like
also those numbers like to be clear are
not from the fbi they're from they're
from they're from
journalist reporting organizations who
are going through newspapers to figure
out what are violent and they're
defining as far right yeah well they're
they're trying to pick up the pieces but
honestly this this work has not been
done at a government level it's only and
it's been done in an academic but
i want to get back to that point because
i don't think we got a chance to flush
it out yeah so my point was that um
there's uh substantially more far left
polarization and extremism compared to
the right and i'll and i'll to make my
point
let me ask you a question if you went to
a uh would you fear violence against you
at a right-wing rally
um
i've got i've always gone along really
well with far-right people like i quite
like them like i like i i i just just
real quick for the sake of argument you
you wouldn't really oh i definitely
would you well there i mean when you go
to a far-right rally there are many many
people walking around with large weapons
i don't know what a far-right rally is
so so just
you know i've been on the ground for uh
uh i went on the ground for maybe like
also i look like this i mean i'm like
i'm like a white dude from alberta so
you you'd be more likely to get attacked
by the far left
well i don't i've never felt threatened
by the far left now
um
you know
i'll give you i'll give you excuses let
me give you an example like i attended
the 2016 inauguration i covered it for
canadian magazine uh the what i fear
genuinely
is not really either side it's when the
two sides are together
like that's what's scary donald trump's
inauguration yeah there were there were
about 400 black-clad leftists smashing
windows starting fires and and attacking
people in the streets yeah there were
there were plenty of far-right groups
there too but they weren't doing
anything well
they were sort of triumphantly there too
well there was there was some violence
but i i would say that the atmosphere of
menace like you're you're just asking me
my feelings right so so it's just you
know
it's
my personal experience but there's also
a really big you look like you looked
him i mean like if you were if you were
a black woman and you were at a
far-right rally i think that would be a
completely different thing and like that
that's one of the things that i've
always found like
far right people get along with me very
very well like i like talking to them
they're
like they're they're nice guys like like
honestly like they're they're
they're perfectly polite you want to
know what i saw in portland i saw the
far left screaming the n-word over and
over again at right-wingers i saw the
proud boys with a bunch of different
people of different races and there was
a black proud boy who was walking down
the street and antifa was screaming
incessantly the n-word at him i've i've
been on the ground on all these things
daryl davis we have very different
experiences of these things for sure are
you familiar with daryl davis no i don't
know who that is he's the black jazz
musician who he decided you know he
thought to himself one day how could
someone hate me if they don't know me so
he started going to clan meetings
oh yes that guy yeah he's fantastic and
we booked him to speak at an event
called ending what was it called ending
violence uh racism and authoritarianism
he was our keynote our headline speaker
to talk about de-radicalization antifa
threatened to burn the theater down so
they canceled on us
the the after show venue refused to back
down so antifa came and protested and he
said
look guys don't worry i'm gonna go talk
to him and when he went out there they
started screaming at him chanting at him
and wouldn't let him speak he wrote a
facebook post which went viral where he
said i've never experienced anything
like this that i was able to go and talk
to clan members as a black man but he
couldn't even talk to these leftist
activists outside without them screaming
at him well look all i can tell you is
the experts i talk to the people that
study this stuff
are much more afraid of the right than
the left now could it be that they are
on the left
well i would they're from foreign
countries
so so the answer is yes they get left i
guess so i mean if they're from belgium
yes they're on the left well i think see
i'm gonna go back to i'm gonna go back
to one thing you said i think if you
went to
i haven't been to a far-right rally i've
been to trump rallies um my experience
have been has been that if you are a
black woman people will go so much
further out of their way to be
accommodating because they want to
demonstrate that much more
that they are not racist because they
have been pinned by the left as you are
a trump person you must be a racist can
i just and i think i find that amazing
that that
that's what has to be done but that is
what happens don't you think that time
has come to stop asking yourselves who
is more to blame
and start figuring out
either how do we reconcile this or how
do we come to some kind of conclusion
that it's not violent i mean
you're you're talking about like
all of this stuff like you're like look
at you're you're getting yourselves
really angry about this oh god no
not in the slightest bit no no look
no no no that's not fair just because
it's a heated conversation
listen i'm not i'm not blaming anyone
i'm just saying like the point of this
book
is really that the moment has come where
you have to ask yourself
how do we get ourselves out of this
cycle of of
those people are awful oh we're all
people our people are awful but that's
in response like that's the crisis that
is facing you is no longer one of who is
right but like how do you how do you
work out these structures into a way
well here's a civilized and and that is
civilized and is you kill it
i know the answer you got to give them
something to live for and you got to
unify people i just with a with an idea
civil war is the worst thing that can
happen oh for sure death is the worst
election being conquered by a foreign
country is nothing compared to civil war
it's the like like it's it's the worst
thing that can happen to a country it's
a disaster china will come in if this
escalates so well you're gonna need like
in part of the book i'm like imagining
what it would be like to have a
negotiated settlement with the united
states which would have to be
internationally monitored and we love
that in this country yeah we love
foreign america live more than chinese
peacekeepers on the ground again i have
my bias and i'm very well aware that i
have my bias so so no bones about it but
so go after me but let me make my point
yeah so you said when you talk when you
look at political assassinations or
political murders based on you said
those numbers were based on journalists
who dig into the assassination is
political violence and you they were
done based on journalists who dug into
the story and read it in five years from
now if a journalist reads an op-ed in
the las vegas post which talked about um
the black lives matter uh attempted
murder in louisville they called him a
right-wing trump supporter basically
they said that this is the cause of
right-wing violence and they said
although he has not and if you read the
op-ed and i sent it to lydia because i
was so apoplectic again if you if you as
of now he has not been identified to any
right-wing groups but this is trump
violence this is this is an editorial in
the las vegas sun after it came out that
he was a black lives matter activist so
you want to say to that editorial board
what are you doing right like why are
you writing a story saying this is a
right-wing extremist who shot a jewish
tried to kill a jewish man running for
for mayor when all of the evidence there
says he is a left-wing radical but but
i'll answer that yeah okay and then i
want to make answer our point you made i
don't want to hear your answer to my
question because like i think you're a
very interesting case of somebody who
has lived through complementary
radicalization and i would like to know
how you
see escaping from it there isn't an
escape
but the the uh to your point
they're
it's a conflict yeah they're going to
say what they need to say to support
their side by any means by any means
necessary and so you actually have
groups called like by any means
necessary the reason why there is no
escape so you asked me if um i am uh
phrase it but like if i am subject to
complementary
well i i'm curious like i don't know if
i like i don't know you but i would like
i i you seem to me like that you would
fit into that category that i've seen
sociologists describe i mean maybe
that's not fair and if it's not please
tell me no no
it is without a doubt but um i don't i i
think
the the issue at hand is
what's the best example to give um
the truckers in in canada are a really
great example
i supported occupy wall street their
right to protest
i interviewed people on the ground
i defended um extinction rebellion when
they blocked the streets in in dc and
put up a boat and said we demand to be
heard when ron desantis was working in
florida on the anti-riot law i said yeah
it is wrong to make it a felony to block
a road those who make peaceful
revolution impossible make violent
revolution inevitable
see i'm the opposite i want the all
bands
but here's what happens
the same people that i met 10 years ago
who defended the right to occupy streets
are now opposed to it in ottawa well so
it was a very different situation
because it's been going on for three
weeks and occupy wall street went on for
two months well i was supposed to occupy
wall street and you also had the chaz in
the chop you also had minneapolis but
it's not about yours it's not about your
views right it's about the fact that we
have
we have in this country
two parent factions within those parent
factions we describe them as left and
right it's fairly nebulous you have
several smaller groups many of them
don't like each other
antifa people don't like democrats but
often they hate them but their politics
do align sometimes
well barely but but institutionally
right so the democrats support black
lives matter to try and earn votes which
then gives funding to say the federal
government gave funding for for profit
relief that the illinois government then
gave directly to black lives matter i
believe it was 300 000
that would never happen with the oath
keepers that would never happen with the
proud boys in fact the proud boys get
called terrorists and evil and demonized
so here's my point when you look at
civics data civic some if you're not if
you're not familiar there are polling
organization that have a massive map a
time spread going back like five years
of all these different issues you can
see that independent voters people who
are unaffiliated right now
overwhelmingly agree with the right when
it comes to issues of the economy when
it comes to issues of job presidential
performance when it comes to black lives
but you know why that is right why is
that because there are no independent
voters in america anymore it's only
about seven percent
i think the last one is a four percent
like so so lots of people on the right
call themselves independent but like if
you talk about like voting behavior like
people who actually shift like vote
democrat sometimes and vote republican
sometimes that that percentage in
america
negligible it's always been negligible
yes that's true and independent voters
have always somewhat leaned democrat
republicans would win if they could
convince just enough to move on the
other side republicans call themselves
independent on a much higher level
that's why that number's out but what
we're seeing now with pew data is that
there's a specific graph showing
hyperpolarization and you have a larger
portion of democrats becoming republican
independence becoming republican than
the inverse so here's what i see i see
my views mostly unchanged on principle
save the second amendment
since the past in the past several years
i went from moderate to a we should
respect people's rights but maybe have
some gun control now i'm just outright
you got to change the constitution
before you can do any of the stuff
second amendment second amendment that's
chapter five so
but you you know to have um
in this country people who are
uninformed on policy or or a specific
industry
try to regulate it and then fail
repeatedly that's exactly why one of the
reasons my positions on this changed
right so when i say something yes i see
what you mean but so so
let me explain the complementary
radicalization please it's not that
my positions have become
far right it's not that my positions
have become increasingly conservative
nope i've always been pro-choice for
much in fact i used to be further left
when i was 18. then i became fairly
liberal and i've remained there save uh
gun rights i became a little bit more
libertarian
the issue is that the other side is
increasingly becoming authoritarian the
left is in is increasingly embracing uh
insane tactics that are destabilizing
the system and then of course i do watch
the right respond in turn
now this is a storm there is no way out
of it but i'll be damned if i'm going to
give up my principles to try and
negotiate with psychopaths so when i say
something but you you just acknowledge
like see this to me seems to be a key
point you're like well the right
response the same way so surely you've
got to get to a point in your country
or just for your own soul where you're
like the psychopaths are everywhere we
need to find a way out from the
psychopaths it's not just the problem is
not just the other side's psychopaths
it's all of the psychopaths well so let
me put it this way
if a guy comes in if i'm in the middle
of a field and i watch two guys and one
guy's like hanging out with this kid and
they're playing catch
and then some dude in a black mask walks
up and punches in the back of the head
he turns around and starts fighting i'm
not going to be like oh no a fight can
we please compromise i'm going to be
like that dude punch that guy arrest him
arrest him that guy's defending himself
but you know somewhere there's some guy
who's in a left-leaning podcast who
thinks exactly the same thing except
from the other side he thinks but he's i
mean
like does it matter it does so i don't
think it matters well listen
joe biden right
it is joe biden is not the source of
this no no but i'll give you an example
joe biden
based on all available journalism and
research we've done engaged in a very
serious criminal act with ukraine we
have reporting from the new york times
we have report we have his own
statements we've got matt taibi's
reporting we have sworn affidavits out
of ukraine from victor shoken as opposed
to the fully legal activities of donald
trump well give me a specific example
of like i'm just donald trump's illegal
i mean he's about to be charged don't
make the mistake of creating false
binaries and trump has nothing to do
with each other specifically citing joe
biden taking a very specific action with
with respect to ukraine that any
reasonable person can look at the
journalism coming out of this and be
like wow what he did there now look by
all means call out donald trump for any
criminal activity he may have done but
everyone seems to do it he seems to be
in the hot seat 24 7. he was under
investigation for a hoax the russia gate
hoax was just not true but that doesn't
happen to the to the establishment
democrat side or the leftists black
lives matter engages in in wanton
destruction in some of the smallest
towns in this country over two billion
dollars in damage
and you and you'll and your perspective
is the right is more dangerous
it's not really my perspective i i would
say that would be the general
perspective of
experts on civil war and the conditions
of the united states i mean those are
the models that i'm working from right
like but i would say like
surely you can see that
these these sides that each side has a
case
and that they and that the problem here
is not the problem here is not that
you know what has happened but the fact
that there's no way for anyone
you know democracies only work
when
if you lose you're the other side is
still valid
right like that those are the conditions
that those are the only those are the
conditions of democracy
and so that like what you're saying to
me
is
what i hear is that um that's no longer
possible and that's that's really what
the book is about and that is
like
i'm kind of like i'm imploring you as a
neighbor this is a book written out of
love this is not this is not a book
written out of contempt for the united
states this is a book written out of
profound love for the united states this
is someone who has i've lived in the
united states i've worked there i have a
lot of american friends i have my trump
voting cousin in seattle like you know
i've got like i've i i feel i can't you
know i think canada has a kinship
relationship with america where we're
you know northrop frye the great
literary canadian literary critic said
that a canadian is an american who
rejects the revolution and i think
that's largely true right
quebec was asked
he said no they said no very close
though i mean you know like the other
thing is i come we almost took montreal
by 1812 no you had the worst general
yeah you had a terrible terrible general
in 1812. the real danger was 1860. but
um
where was i i now have completely lost
my trust
my point though is that
like as someone who is concerned for
your country and as someone who wants
you to have a stable country like you
are gonna have to get to a point where
this is the either come to some kind of
divorce
which seems to me like a
at this when a marriage reaches the
point that the united states is at you
say you'd sit the kids down and say like
it's over but or will lead to violence
well i don't think there's a way to
avoid violence at this point the
question is how do we get out of it
let me ask you a question stop focusing
on the psychopaths and start focusing on
what's causing psychopathy because if
you try and wipe out the psychopaths
they're just gonna keep appearing
exactly it's not trying to drown a
vampire in blood but let me let me ask
you then um you want to end the conflict
okay what i want is for america to
survive as democracy all right so that
is what i want very specifically how do
you feel about your healthcare system in
canada i love it okay get rid of that
and go fully private we got a deal
yeah no you wait no no no no no you have
to compromise with me right will you
give up your your state fund your safety
you know that's a fair point
you mean you make it you that's that's
fair i'm sitting i see what you mean i'm
sitting here with people telling me
that so so uh uh i'm gonna go right into
the stereotype for everybody who's
listening i come from a second
generation mixed race family okay they
fought in my my my grandparents were
forced to flee numerous states because
it was illegal to cohabitate and have
kids this is something my family
experienced i grew up once again with my
mom whose mixed race marrying a white
guy and having a second generation mixed
race family and i genuinely believed
when i was a kid growing up in chicago
like we had we had come to this position
where we recognized race was less
important martin luther king junior's
dream i was gonna it didn't matter what
i was or my latino friend or my asian
friend we were all just friends in the
neighborhood and then i got to
experience critical race theory and
these people looked me in the eyes and
said i don't know what you are so you're
not allowed to be in any of these groups
but all the white people go there the
black people go there the asians go
there and the mexicans go there that's
what they did at occupy wall street they
were called spokes the spokes council
and they said there were working groups
and there were caucuses and the caucus
caucuses were race-based and
gender-based and so they quite literally
said if you want to vote on how we spend
money all the black people have to go in
the group of black people and decide how
black people want money spent and i said
that's insane and i will fight against
that tooth and nail because my family
experienced this in this past election
in california they tried to repeal their
civil rights amendment from their
constitution i ask you
you say that we've got to come to this
position where we come together would
you be willing to allow a bunch of white
people in a majority white state to
discriminate against black people in the
name of peace
you know i don't think i'm gonna be
faced with that question and certainly
the world is perplexing to me enough
without what-ifs but i'd actually like
to ask you a question because i don't
i don't know the answer to this even
after i spent five years writing this
thing
like
how do you think this is going to end
i don't i i mean i've heard you say
there's going to be a civil war
i think we're in a civil war i mean i
think you're well you're literally in
civil strife like like in in attack
you're in a technical sense like you are
already technically in civil strife and
that was 27 deaths per year or something
no it's 25 but uh like america is a
funny [ __ ] like america's so big and so
diverse and so geographically huge that
those numbers are probably not as
meaningful as they are in the rest of
the world but on the other hand i think
we're in agreement right is it an older
metric like no it's a standard metric
but it's still not it like
you know america's america is different
right like america is a very different
place like i don't think america is an
exception i don't think the laws of
political gravity don't apply to the
united states but
like when you're applying these
standards it's just a little it's just a
little more complicated than it would be
for canada right um but on the other
hand
like how do you actually so you you
think that do you think political
violence is going to become normalized
that there's just going to be a lot more
assassination do you think there's going
to be do you think there's going to be
street fights do you like
all of those things i can't foresee a
scenario in like you know one of the
problems here is that by 2040 uh 50 of
the country will control 85 percent of
the senate right so this is like this
becomes like this is classic enocracy so
you know civil wars tend to happen
in
like civil wars don't happen in full
democracies like denmark and they don't
happen in autocracies like russia they
happen when there's a in the gray area
right in this in this area where
it's unclear whether it's democracy or
autocracy so do you think like i can't
foresee a scenario where there will be
an uncontested election ever in the
united states oh you're you're
completely correct i mean going back to
uh uh since
uh gore and bush
yeah it's just been and even then you
still had uh
certain some degree of of strife and
insanity with previous elections but it
was really bad starting then
um
there's there's a bunch of different
ways i i see this
i don't think the right wants to control
the left but the left does want to
control the right
so
the right ones to control the country i
disagree
i think so you think the right would be
happy with just the states controlling
their own because i mean one one answer
to this is radical defederalization yes
i mean that's something that's been told
but we are we are supposed to be
radically de-federalized yeah i mean
we're not well you already know what i
mean but no but but we're not we're not
the fact that compared compared to other
people radically compared to other
countries like compared to any country
in europe compared to anywhere in asia
like you are radically de-federalized as
you were traveling the country writing
this geographically did you find
intensity in certain areas
well um
i'm just curious like
because it is a big country
as you were traveling the country
writing this book when you were in state
x where you were like wow i really feel
a a
a burgeoning civil war here new york
city i'm from new york city no i uh
texas not to knock texas did you go to
any region that you were like these
people are ready to be separated i found
it i found it everywhere really yeah i
mean it was extraordinary to me the
where i would find it like my friends
who are in media in the hudson valley
they feel very much under threat like
they feel they feel like if you run for
dog catcher as a democrat in hudson
valley someone will send you a picture
of a gun saying we're coming for you
right like never mind
but i mean the thing about america right
now is that everyone feels under siege
right like everyone feels under siege
from one kind or another whether it's
cultural siege whether it's political
siege whether it's siege from the
political machinery right that's the
extraordinary thing right i'm going to
talk to you guys you all feel under
siege yeah
i feel like
i'm going to go down degrees with
like they're trying to take they're
they're hitting me in the back of the
head in an open field and well no no
they're trying to tell me
to you understand in a segregated world
exactly and i will go and i will go and
talk to black lives matter organizers
which i have also done and they will
they will say exactly the same thing
they will say they will say literally
exactly the same thing and they're lying
to you
that's what they say about you yes
exactly and and and
when russia gate was a hoax when the
covington kids was a hoax when jesse
smellet was a hoax at a certain point
don't you say to yourself maybe they're
lying to me well
then there's the
you know then there's january 6th and
then there's then there's trump calling
up the tanks in washington on the fourth
of july well then there's what is that
what is that well in the fourth of july
yeah but but hold on hold on oh sorry am
i not close enough
but like that's not a lie
january
i don't do the rage so if you want to
have someone on to explain to you the
crimes or the right like if you could
definitely find a lot of people if i'm
gonna cite overt
widespread lies and then you cite
january 6 which is unrelated to what i
was talking about i'm going to ask you
oh i think you're asking
well i i mean if i were to count trump's
lies
that's a lo i mean how many hours do we
have here like but like i mean if we're
gonna if we're gonna talk about the the
lies of the right like any trump speech
has 30 of them yeah i don't like but
hold on hold on comparing trump and
they're both i'm talking about i'm not
talking about one guy trump is a symptom
of this this i actually say that in the
book you know he's a symptom rather than
a cause right sure so when you have if
you're talking about if you're asking me
like are there any right wing people who
lie that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying
you you would say that black lives
matter would accuse me of lying and my
response is jesse smallett that thing
was an obvious lie but it was picked up
by actors and celebrities and every
mainstream news organization russia gate
was three four years of outright lying
ukraine gate all of it turned to be lies
hands up don't shoot another lie the
covington kids another lie 11 trump
associates have been indicted but
indictments don't mean anything other
than people are at war with each other
john durham is investigating them the
same as they're investigating him what
i'm talking about are you really going
to argue with me are you actually gonna
say that the trump administration was an
honest administration you don't believe
i didn't say that
okay so you would admit that they're
lying oh absolutely well there we go but
my point is
trump is
how many viewers does the right command
in terms of institutional media
10 million relative to fox news is the
biggest news organization in the country
by far except they only get about like
three million in total well yeah i mean
we're in media breakdown this is
actually actually a large part of the
structure too like the information
breakdown that's also a big part of the
book but like it's that's actually
that's a you know when i talked about a
complex cascading system that's that
feeds into both sides in in different
ways in asymmetrical ways but um but you
know like one one way of thinking about
this struggle is that it is a memetic
struggle in the jeff joseah you know so
the definition of it here's the point
i'm trying to get to um if you look at
the politically homeless faction the
intellectual dark web faction the
post-liberal faction yes conservatives
and even hardcore maga trump supporters
they all agree for the most part on a
typical world view except for certain
like q elements which don't make up that
many i i
i don't think i can really agree with i
mean i really tried i mean maybe it is
my own failing but i mean part of my job
was trying to figure out like what are
the intellectual coherences that you
find in this and i found out i mean one
of the things i find really interesting
about the american right in general is
their um
their love of esoteric information right
like an esoteric knowledge where like
something becomes more valuable because
it's less believed
what's an example of that if you have
one well q anon would be like the
ultimate example but where like
prominent i mean you have q anon is
pretty powerful i mean there's two
congress there's 50 people going to run
in 2022 who are queuing on but what does
that mean
well uh 50 50 members of the republican
party support q and on they're going to
run and see here here's here's the issue
i think you might have we've had
marjorie taylor on the show yeah and
she's she's rejected all of that stuff
so when you don't actually do space
lasers and so on that's not true
actually that's a lie
right so if you if you base your
perception off a faction that it's lying
to you non-stop of course you're going
to believe well the both sides must be
bad margaritas do not understand that
i've had this con this exact
conversation with people on the left and
i've i've actually stated exactly this
in 100 plus shows of this that that the
reason civil war in my opinion is
inevitable is because you have two sides
both saying i'm right i'll give you i'll
give you an example a riddle
uh you may have heard this one this will
be fun for all the kids at home don't
tell me i want to guess
you come across you're walking down a
road and you come to a fork in the road
and you see
there's there's two paths and uh and and
you know that once one road will lead
you to a minute death and one road will
lead you to safety there are two men
standing on each side oh yes the old one
and how do you know one always tells the
truth one always a lie i know how
as i've heard it as heaven and hell yeah
where one the angel always tells the
truth and the devil always tells a lie
and you asked the devil
no no you asked the angel is the other
one at death you don't know
which one is which [ __ ] i can't remember
you that's fine
yeah i can't remember it i've heard it
you ask either one of them what the
other would say right and then take the
opposition take the opposite path yeah
so so the issue here is
there there is obviously
a more complex system of variables here
well that's my point but
right like that's that's that's actually
a really good way of putting it
so if if that's the condition where
one's the angel and one's the devil and
you don't know
which one is right
like surely we have to come up with
something more clever than the other
side's wrong
i suppose the issue is um
the reason i use the biden example is
because if you were to ask
the average journalist in this country
did joe biden engage in a quid pro quo
in ukraine they will tell you no but the
actual answer is yes he did i i think
journalists actually are pretty
complicated i mean i know a lot of them
you know as i said i'm a freelance
writer so one of the advantages i have
is that i go into a lot of shops i'm
like a stray cat like i go into the wall
street journal in the new york times in
new york or the atlantic and so on like
and i i would say that the
the general opinion that the american
media are all the same
that's not that's not necessarily true
what is true is that people went to ivy
league schools
tend to be tend to have a a very similar
outlook on life these these
organizations uh most of them are new
york or they tend to be in big cities
where they're surrounded by like-minded
people i won't say they're they're only
as far as i know they're only in new
york washington and l.a but let me ask
you to uh because i think the best
example is the biden thing were you
aware that joe biden engaged in a
criminal quid pro quo i'm not sure i
would define it that way but also i'm
not sure i have that whole story so this
is like and you know when i don't like
there's a lot of things why don't you
you know i was with the president well
there was a bunch i was at a i was at a
cottage with these
friends i have who are in their 80s and
one guy told me to really they were all
giving me life advice and this old dude
said you know one of the most important
things in life is to know you don't have
to have an opinion on everything
you don't have to think
i know the answer to x when you don't
and so i actually go through life
not knowing the answer to almost
everything and so when i write books
what i try and do is figure out exactly
what i do know
and like and like and also be clear
about where i got my knowledge let me
see like i don't like what happened with
biden in the ukraine i don't know
shouldn't you though i mean if you're
writing about a civil war and there have
been accusations made up against donald
trump in terms of a quid pro quo i don't
remember donald trump does not figure in
this book
like neither does biden like to me
honestly horse race politics irrelevant
yeah like like horseradish like what
margery taylor green said what ted cruz
said today irrelevant like the
structural problems that the united
states faces are so profound
that
all of the politics to me that consumes
everything in is all irrelevant like it
it really really does not matter the the
reason i bring it up is just um to try
and set like a baseline so yeah i i
started uh covering occupy wall street i
had worked i had been an activist in my
younger years i worked for nonprofits i
go to occupy wall street i start
documenting things and i say i just want
to show people what's happening i end up
getting a job advice and being the
founding member of vice news right doing
on-the-ground reporting in ukraine and
brazil and venezuela and then from there
i went and joined abc univision's joint
venture once again trying to do news but
that's where they got hyper-polarized
they within six months of me being there
they said we're far left that's our
that's our pitch right we are targeting
progressive young people oh as a
freelancer you think i don't see that
but so institutions all the time that
i'm part of suddenly become
hyper-polarized but it's always to the
left
well
yes no that you're fair that's fair so
here's
they almost always go hyper polarized
left so so then they immediately die
like that's the other thing vice's
evaluation right right like they like
they go
that's one of my points about the left
is like once you once an institution
becomes woke it almost immediately
started that's my favorite about the
federal reserve i'm gonna make this
point slow like i gotta i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry i don't mean to interrupt you
no i know i'm talking a lot this one but
i do wanna make this point is that as a
baseline
i've been reading the news and doing the
research and the fact checking on all of
these stories and it's come to a point
where
the right tends to be correct on these
things and the left goes off into wally
world every time ukraine gate being a
really great example of the corporate
press the the establishment democrats
and the left all lying about what joe
biden did with respect to ukraine when
more and more reporting keeps coming up
proving he actually did this even based
on the mainstream his own previous
reporting say from politico
publishes a story as does the new york
times that ukrainians meddled in the
2016 election in an effort to help
democrats not that the ukrainian
government did but that elements of you
know higher ranking officials in ukraine
did
a court even ruled this in ukraine joe
biden engages in a quid pro quo where he
brags about it on camera
but if you come out and say that you're
called right wing they say it's fake
news you're lying and it's not true i
live in a world based on do you have
sources for that just the other night we
got reporting that the person who tried
to assassinate the democrat was a blm
activist and i said no no no no no
we are not that is a rumor is not
confirmed until we can get official
confirmation on this story even though
there had been i just hadn't seen it
because if i don't have the official
reporting from a trusted source it
didn't happen but every single time i go
to the news a good majority of what's
considered mainstream corporate press is
out right wrong and they defend it for
example the crack pipe story jen sackey
goes on tv and says we were never going
to give out crack pipes that's a lie
easily proved by looking at the
organizations they were contracting who
give crack pipes i pulled up two
different sources international and
national that say safe smoking kits
include meth and crack pipes yet when
when the right comes out and says this
snope says false all of the corporate
establishment press are saying it's not
true there were never any crack pipes
then gentecki goes on tv and says why
did they go crack pipes why why was
there an objection to them giving out
crack pipes the right felt it could
possess
exacerbate crack pipe smoke
see in canada i remember in the 90s
there was this bad there was a i
remember going to parties and there was
a government program to give out um
straws for snorting cocaine
because it was because it was being uh
aids was being communicated nasally and
so i remember i was like yeah that's
that's just the government i like they
give out
someplace for stories
do you honestly are you honestly telling
me that you feel like when you see
something on fox news you feel like it's
probably correct and then it's not and
then it's and then it's and that you've
never seen a story on fox news that was
not was a lie no i call out fox news
it's just i call them out lessons well
then what are i mean
and foxes
the problem here the problem here is the
informational networks it's not the
sides that's what i'm trying to tell you
but what ends up happening is after a
decade of this
it has become so divergent
that you cannot convince an 18 year old
who's voting for these policies that the
majority of their life was based on lies
so i'll give you another example of
what's caused all this and i don't know
if you looked into this but um in the
late have you looked at the lexus nexus
data on cr on critical race theory and
woke terminology
no i don't i have not checked that at
the end of 2000 of the 2000s lexus nexus
tracks massive spikes in the new york
times saying things like white privilege
racism class privileges you don't need
lexisnexis to tell you that right well
so several things happened one
millennials who are in colleges who are
being who are learning these things
started to age into the workforce but
the biggest thing that happened was
facebook created the algorithms that
prop up content based on how many
keywords are in them so someone who's
eight years old it goes on facebook and
they start getting inundated with videos
of police brutality for 10 years why
because it clicks really well anger and
justice themes do really really well on
facebook but so does the opposite dude i
mean definitely i mean like and your
injustice can go either way well
like the
i mean
i i i feel like i'm repeating myself but
like
surely we can all see that like i i've
i've definitely not been a friend to
wokeness you can read my right you can
read my writing on it like i've been
punished enough
but like like just to be clear like
what would
my point here is really this that the
crisis that your country is facing is so
severe
that
that these these debates are
increasingly meaningless because they
take place in a context of
you know essentially semantic collapse
dude you can see people in the metaverse
wearing with black avatars and with
white avatars doesn't matter if they're
black or white in real life but you'll
see them segment into their little
avatars in the game and they're going to
act like real life as if it's real let
me let me people are wired to people i
want to make this point and we can
change that but samantha collapse i want
to hear what you think about it but so
so uh like i want your opinion on that
but let me curious about that so the you
already mentioned that these new these
media organizations tend to drift left
well
there's there's both fox definitely
has gone way right
tucker carlson has become increasingly
more populist and supportive of previous
left-wing positions now hannity i'm not
a big fan of but hold on hold on there a
minute
mike.com is a really great example and
uh uh i'll tell you why i think this is
happening and probably why it is
happening mike.com when they first
started they were libertarian they were
pro ron paul right but within a few
years they became completely woke why
at facebook and twitter and youtube what
is deemed safe
wokeness so i had this conversation with
jack dorsey for for instance there's
certain things you can't say on social
media it almost always favors the left
but you're massively successful and i'm
just doing the opposite of that and i'm
a centrist i mean come on like like
there are there are certainly right-wing
like
joe rogan joe rowan is not right-wing
well no i wouldn't say he is either
i wouldn't say as either but well then
maybe like the right has been decimated
on social media and so these companies
see the algorithm certainly the left
would say the other thing but there
that's when when when mike.com
starts off libertarian and then becomes
woke when vice.com starts off as an edgy
bro frat boy kind of punk website and
becomes feminist well when hbc news runs
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
six months later says we're going woke
everybody it is not the going the other
direction it's flowing one way no no no
i mean it is just flowing always it's
flowing like the process that's underway
is complementary radicalization
i mean that that is what it is it's like
the right becomes more right because the
left becomes more left have you seen the
pew data on this
well yeah but the pew data you know
unequivocally supports right like the
radicalization online as being a
right-wing phenomenon
that the republican party has moved on a
scale of zero through ten with zero
being left and ten being right they've
moved 1.5 degrees to the right since 94
and the left has jumped three points
yeah but it depends it depends also if
you check the check the racial
resentment numbers which spike hugely
for republicans right so like they're
they're they're they're different
they're a whole bunch of ways of reading
those numbers what are those numbers the
racial racial resentment so racial
resentment is like
well it's a pretty complicated
sociological thing it's a bunch of
different factors but it's like how it's
not necessarily racism per se it's
whether you feel threatened
uh and so that and and so that that
number like rather than being an
ideology like rather than being a
ideology as in i am a racist it is like
how you feel about certain aspects of
life so
and those numbers were identical for
democrats and republicans in i think
1990. and then they again don't quote me
on that but i want to address the
semantic
yes because i would really like
you know we're here we're doing the show
people are listening to it right now
what are we doing to prevent semantic
breakdown
well i don't know i mean having a
conversation that clarifies definitions
like marxism for instance is probably
helpful right racism has come to mean
completely different things well that's
not it's that's essentially uh well i i
don't know that that
you know i've been doing this for so
long that i try to stay extremely
precise
in all the terms like as you said i
don't like to use terrorism unless it is
actually like
the technical definition of terrorism i
like to use like i
part of the book because this stuff is
so fraught i i want to be i want to have
the terminology exact like what is civil
war what is civil strife what is someone
well i think you can be but um it
requires um a certain amount of loss
it requires a certain amount of loss of
force uh in your argument for sure it
does the the humility the left and the
right uh the right has a traditional
view of language like
we use words that mean things they meant
20 years ago and the left has redefined
things
well the left is involved in a language
etiquette that is totally destructive
and
and just as self-consuming as i said
like there is a there is a well i mean
as mark said in the german ideology like
there was a man who thought
if i define river differently no one
will drown right that's there and that's
what that's what the left has become
where they think that definitions will
they think that definitions will change
reality i have a good example of what i
think is uh contributing to the
breakdown and why i think there's no
solution i feel like many on the right
are looking for an anchor like just tell
me where we stand and what
where we are and i'll try and figure out
what's going on whereas the left just
says i will do as the as the tide flows
so the example on this is but the left
eats itself well certainly they're a
swamp but that doesn't mean let me
finish this point sorry well nobody goes
away i mean if people went away it would
be easier the point i was going to make
is i saw meme recently where
someone was talking about uh vaccines
and then someone responded
they they said uh someone made the meme
about seat belts they were like oh we
should ban seat belt mandates and
someone said
you know i hate to break it to you but
seat belts aren't intended to prevent an
accident they're prevented to reduce
your risk of injury in the event one
happens and then all the people on the
left started laughing saying how stupid
do you have to be that's literally what
vaccines do the problem is for people on
the right joe biden came out publicly
and addressed the nation saying vaccines
prevent transmission and dr fauci and
they all said something very similar now
i understand science changes but it's
very difficult to latch onto something
if it goes back and forth so people well
i mean we're dealing like the the the
situation with like this is a chaotic
moment of of real chaos but this is like
this is not that has nothing to do with
semantic chaos that has to do with the
fact of trying to figure things out also
suddenly there's omicron suddenly i mean
people are people are doing this on the
well you're that's that's that's that's
just you know stuff happens like you're
just trying to figure out what the hell
i am not saying you know fault on either
side on this what i'm saying one of the
things that that is causing a divide is
people have different tolerances for a
change in information or they have
expectations that's possible although it
seems to me like
the radicalization is happening you know
at the same level
and and happening uh
and
don't you feel everyone's out there
looking for an anchor i mean god knows
the people i talk to on the left are
desperate for some kind of stability i
mean that's the one hope i have is that
you know the the chaos has become so
intolerable to people that they that
they need some kind of they they really
start to crave they need structures
dared to step through the fire so uh
again to throw it back to jesse smilet
for instance covington kids big cultural
moments that were absolutely wrong
for a lot of people that you know we've
even had on the show they've said
this was the moment i said i just can't
live this way anymore and i need
something solid and so i said i can't
trust these people keep lying to me and
i look for something else
i mean those are very specific moments
like what's the what's the technical
term for the the fallacy where you take
one example and exclude it to everything
else i mean you know everyone has their
example god knows there's a lot of
tolerance because god there's enough
chaos out there there's enough nonsense
but
you know
why like why because they never they
never apologized they never admitted it
see i think
not to be too much of a salesman like
not like i don't like
you actually have a lot of information
about this that i don't have but i think
what i try to do in my book is go 30 000
feet in the air
i think i think your requires a lot of
information i don't have in people yes i
think it does but
to to go like i think we need some
perspective on this stuff like jesse
small is not a major incident in
american history
it's a grain of sand in a heap
but it wasn't a joke in the sense the
way institutions latched onto it the way
elected officials latched onto it the
media latched on to it and i think one
of the ways where i don't want to say i
disagree with you but when we see the
world differently i do not see the right
trying to cancel the left the way the
left tries to cancel the right small
example of that you have this lovely
singer british chick adele who won an
award and because of the current time
period
a week ago it was a gender-neutral
artist of the year and in her acceptance
speech she said i wish it weren't i
won't fake a british accent i wish it
weren't uh although she's cockney i wish
it weren't artist of the year i wish it
were
woman of the year because i love being a
woman that turned into adele's trying to
cancel the trans movement adele should
be banned on spotify stop buying adele i
don't ever see that on the right and
proof of that is
two years ago the nfl they kneel at the
anthem stop watching the nfl no one
stopped watching well there's no one
look at the super bowl numbers look at
the playoff numbers the right can't go
to a cancel culture the way the left can
what would have to happen for people to
stop watching the nfl it's unimaginable
i don't know exactly like the the civil
war could happen but but the nfl is
gonna continue but look at the movement
to get taylor swift to pull her record
off of spotify because of joe rogan i
don't think you see that on the right
there are calls for it certainly there
are calls for it we should stop the nfl
being the best example we should stop
watching the nfl but they don't but see
yeah
in the heat yes no no fair enough i'm
worried about commentary what the less
worried about is that the west's worried
about is that by 2040 50 of the country
is going to be and 50 of the senate is
going to sorry 85 of that senate is
going to be controlled by 50 of the
country that's a good thing but that's
well i mean that really to me devolves
into like pseudo-democracy or a
constitutional republic not a democracy
uh well see this is where we get into
it's time to separate because like i
think there are two visions of america
one is a constitutional republic a
settler republic and the other is a
multicultural democracy and i think they
are fundamentally irreconcilable i agree
and they and and then they actually
they're actually you need two countries
because like the time has come for
uh like these are both visions that have
their merits and they have their
demerits right but you know certainly i
am on the side of multicultural
democracy
all day forever um that's where i come i
mean like 51
decides the law
uh yeah with minority protections yeah
minority
well those are by law so those are not
well i mean if you actually want to know
what i believe it's the charter of
rights and freedoms of the canadian
constitution which is incredibly
specific and was written in 1982 and
contains all of this beautifully
articulated in a
simple way but but my point really here
is like
like whichever side you're on of this
these two countries can't coexist like
it has to be one or the other and it
really can't be both i'd like to see
people democratically choosing where
their tax dollars go right but also
having some sort of republicanism that's
why i'm just a point oh that would be an
idea of an amalgam
america has been an amalgam america is a
massive contradiction and you know the
beauty of america its great gift is has
been its capacity to hold contradictory
ideas at the same time um like that is
that is the glory of america and that's
because it's a constitutional republic
it's able to well i think actually it's
when you go back to the original
constitution it contains a whole coast
of political ideas that are in conflict
and also you know it believes in it
believes in in struggle as it believes
in disagreement i mean that's that's the
amazing gift of the american
constitution is that it believes that
you don't need
unity you need disagreement to get to
the best answer right but that that only
works if you have a concept of yourself
as a unified whole and when that
evaporates when that dissolves you're
left with
you know
irreconcilability and that like i think
you know have you read washington's
farewell address recently no i mean
it's really worth reading because it's a
great work of genius like it is it's a
really fascinating
book because he
worked because he predicts exactly where
you are right now like exactly where you
are right now and he did it
you know on his retirement i imagine you
did a lot of research on the first
american civil war uh yeah i mean
there's so much work on it like i would
never call myself an expert on that like
i definitely read a lot of books about
it but just you know i'm not i would
never there's some things in here that i
do consider myself an expert on but that
there are so many civil war acts just
because um you asked you asked me
earlier what i thought was gonna happen
we didn't quite get into it yeah i will
say we spend a lot of time um you know
you from 30 000 feet me from someone on
the ground trying to explain my
positions i don't think i need to
explain them to you right the most part
i think you know you wrote a book i
obviously want to explain it to the
audience but um as for what i think is
going to happen
we hear a lot of peaceful divorce you
mentioned these two countries can't
exist but there is in my opinion no
scenario in which there's a peaceful
divorce it's almost impossible and uh
the reason for it is actually someone on
the show brought this up i can't
remember who but they made a great point
uh there's two countries you say
multicultural democracy and
constitutional republic both have their
merits
the first civil war what happened it was
like i think four states legally seceded
yeah everybody was like all right then i
think seven more states joined in and
they all went well okay then and then
the north said but these military bases
are ours and we're going to remain in
them and that's when fort sumter south
carolina they said no no no hold on you
got to leave
nobody believed the muskets were loaded
nobody believed the cannons were were
armed they all thought that it was just
bluster and there would be no fighting
because it could never happen here
that's right and then the bombardment
started no one foresaw the first civil
war yes like no like even though in
hindsight it all seems perfectly clear
and the structures are all there and
it's like there's no way that it
couldn't be a civil war after the
nullification crisis and the mum the the
the uh uh
after whatever happened here right like
harper's ferry like we're like 15
kilometers away from where this happened
but like you know after all that but
even fort sumner i mean jefferson davis
said it's probably nothing yep i bet the
the leaders of the north knew there was
something coming soon
they're like yo we're getting that back
they had to go to europe to buy guns
yeah the north
the industrial super power of the world
in 1850 wow had to go to europe i wonder
how much of our treasury they sold out
for those weapons they bought a lot of
guns and so here's what here's what
happens now
uh uh
so it was a great statement
i think texas had written this that they
had joined the south simply by nature of
geography yes not ideology same thing
would happen today because well they
were texas was a slave state california
free state and that's what that's where
they lined up but they were so nascent i
mean you're talking about you know
you're not talking about large groups of
people right right right in the city in
the first year the idea was and then you
also had slave states who joined the
north by by nature yeah geography yeah
because of geography yeah so what what i
think would happen but there was only
one right maryland i think i think it
was with i think west virginia too west
virginia was not a slave state west
virginia right virginia right okay so
what would happen today is you would
likely have new york illinois california
maybe washington maybe oregon you write
all that stuff i imagine i'm going to
show you the map that i got i want to
know what i know i want to know what you
whether you think it's uh reasonable but
go on please please so i think it could
start with uh rapid de-federalization
but then ultimately what will end up
happening is
one side's going to say
yeah slide that over
one side's what's what's the page number
218. 218. one side's going to say
let me grab this book
hey those those those nukes those
weapons those resources are ours and we
want them the other side's going to say
sorry no dice fighting starts well the
problem is like to negotiate a
settlement you need goodwill right there
are countries that negotiate separation
like czechoslovakia where they do
negotiate in in in goodwill and that's
what happened with norway and sweden
yeah tell me what you think of that i
mean that that is not a wonder what the
best way to show this is actually
because i'm sure i wonder if is there
any so i can't zoom in
well it's basically the north northeast
and then the south and midwest and then
california to oregon and then texas have
you seen the poll i think it was yougov
data showing the different five
different regions of the u.s you've got
the midwest south and they were all
basically saying yeah let's break off
you know what you will really like in
that book is the psychometric data which
is like different personality types by
region which is actually fascinating and
like goes to really deep-seated
structural differences between the
between these groups but that the one
that i had only had three i like how uh
texas is just goes back to texas well
texas like they have they have a very
active nationalist movement that's quite
together and like and also texas would
100 work as a country i i uh what do you
think do you think it's close i think
you're close the only issue is i think
it ends up with uh a bunch of war
well the the problem is that first of
all to negotiate a settlement you need
goodwill and then the u.n to negotiate
with the u.n which i know sounds
ridiculous but you know you can't no one
will land in an airport until you have
u.n agreement that you're a separate
country is really really hard especially
with a country that has security uh
general what's it called security
council
uh placement so like it would be
incredibly difficult let me let me ask
you to negotiate a secession have you
researched abortion
well no that's that's that's
polarization that's part of polarization
of course i did just write about
something about it in lithu about about
the politics of abortion as a factor in
um
in polarization i mean you know the most
bizarre thing about it is that
uh you know the the when this is again
looking at it from a foreign country is
like
abortion in the united states should be
one of the policies that everyone agrees
on like it is a success story like
women get more control of their
reproductive health every year abortion
rates have declined 19
between 2011 and 2017. like if you want
to end abortion in america keep doing
exactly what you're doing like it's not
like it is a
it's a policy success no one can see it
yeah everyone is screaming at each other
no
like everyone someone said is screaming
life the other one is screaming choice
they if you were to ask yourself what
the correct policy is
you would see that the policy is both
like women get control over their
reproductive health
that's what leads to declines in
abortion rates and
so it's a win-win for everyone but
because it's so divided they can't they
can't see those basic facts but so
that's that doesn't that's not really a
contributing factor to what i'm talking
about in the book the the reason i bring
it up is i think it could be a uh strong
moral issue in this civil war
oh it's huge it's a huge thing but there
are a whole bunch of them church
attendance corporal punishment in
schools
uh like there's the sociological factors
that go into it are actually really
significant so are you familiar that the
the supreme court heard oral arguments
on roe v wade yeah well not a rover on
mississippi or mississippi florida just
uh they just
passed a ban after 15 weeks right and so
uh man we we've had a bunch of people in
here we've had legal experts and
everyone seems to agree that roe v wade
will be overturned it's going to cause
so much anger there's already 12 states
that have trigger laws as soon as roe v
wade is overturned instantly done banned
yeah so my question is you mentioned the
far right
is what i've said
do you think
that when that happens do you think
republicans will try to ban abortion
nationally oh i have no idea like that's
not i don't have expertise in that like
i'm sorry but like i just can't really
give an honest or
accurate answer to that question i mean
i would say that once that happens
that
that like one thing that is that it's
that i notice in this book is like the
right has said concept of civil war for
a long time
right like for at least since the 90s
and it was a fringe position but it it
sort of became more mainstream in 2008
but i think the left is actually
starting to catch up right the left is
actually starting to catch up to the
idea that like this country isn't
working its institutions are failing
there's gonna have to be a response to
this and i think abortion could be a
major trigger of it like i think there
are a lot of people who don't you know
you asked me that question like what if
health care
was taken away wait take it away from me
like
it will be like that for them so i i
there's there's a lot to this for one
many uh conservatives have told me no
republicans will never try to ban it
federally not only that they can't it's
not a federal it's not it can't be
federally federally legislated has to be
at the at the state level yeah but um my
question is
do you think there's
any number of right-wing people any
small number who would be willing to go
to an abortion clinic the moment roe v
wade is overturned and say with force
and what you're doing right now
well you know
the criminalization of abortion is one
of the worst policy ideas it's possible
to have because you have to ask yourself
all kinds of questions like
are you going to start are you going to
start a dea
for
abortion sure
but my point is like they're not really
thinking about policy no no for sure but
do you think do you think people would
be alive do you think there would be a
john brown of abortion who's going to
walk up to an abortion doctor and just
blow his brains out but it's already
happened well exactly like a lot like
it's happened many many times like right
there's been a huge amount of violence
around that so it's kind of uh the
question i'm getting well that's see
like when we're talking about the
numbers of what constitutes political
violence that doesn't qualify as
political violence in in the in the
stats that we looked at going up and
killing an abortion doctor but i i of
course would qualify it as that right so
like
yeah like absolutely i think um so so
but it's the point is not really the
violent extremist the point is
do they start a police force like how
are they going to actually manage the
like you know the texas law well so was
not policy it was just like we're going
to start this crazy bounty system that
got i mean no one knows what the hell
that would look like
they don't want to actually answer the
question of what the
what the police regulation of this would
look like especially given the fact that
you know america can't even control the
flow of heroin
i think it's simple i think these red
states are gonna they're gonna shut down
all of their planned parenthoods and
yeah and they've gone a long way already
i mean when you look at proximity to
abortion access in america like red and
blue states i mean just the world of
difference so you either get to a point
where
you know uh california immigrant
sanctuary state they're already defying
federal law then you've got yes they
certainly did in 2016 i mean jeff
sessions that's a big chapter in the
book but i'll tell you what else i mean
new york voting for non-citizens to have
the right to vote massachusetts voting
for non-citizens to get driver's
licenses this is my point like i think
the left is starting to figure out like
that would have been those kind of
defiant actions would have been typical
of uh red states for its whole history
but i think now oh sorry i've got it
mixed up blue you know in everywhere
else in the world red means left and
blue you know why that's conservative
right yeah it was it was 2000 election
right
someone explained it to me yeah but it
used to be the other way around it used
to be the other way around yeah um but
so
now people on the left are figuring out
we're going to be in defiance of federal
authority so
well so uh we've had sanctuary cities on
the left for a long time we've had now
california sanctuary state do you know
how our elections work in this country
the electoral college i've tried well
yeah i mean i tried like as a as i
almost put a chapter in the book about
it but i could not find
unbiased opinion like that was the thing
that was so amazing it's like i can't
find anyone who can explain it to me in
a coke hearing the electoral college
well the electoral college yeah i
understand so uh
in the united states
non-citizens do have voting power in
every single election so when california
says
we are going to allow non-citizens into
this country and provide them benefits
they are seizing federal authority what
the way it works is uh this is i'm sorry
seizing oh okay using federal power yeah
okay they're they're stealing
disproportionate amounts of power within
our federal well i would say they're in
defiance of no no no no no no no they're
actually stealing okay all right so
here's how it works um the electoral
college is based on congressional seats
you get an electoral uh elector vote and
your seats in in congress are based upon
your population size not citizen size
right so when california allows in
non-citizens the census is done
non-citizens are counted and they get
extra congressional representation which
then results in it results in
disproportionate voting power and it
results in disproportionate power to to
elect the president
i think according to the heritage
foundation california last election only
got one additional electoral vote but
when we're talking about you know what
is it 538 i mean that's substantive that
that that's a decent amount of gained
power and it's not just california it's
other sanctuary cities and states so the
left likes to come out and say it's
unfair that the senate is comprised of
you know x amount of senators who come
from only a certain amount of states
when they're engaging in defiance of
federal authority to give themselves
disproportionate votes in in congress
and the electoral college but i mean
it's really kind of much of a muchness
because the the problem here is like i
think you're going to have an election
relatively soon like not i don't know if
it's 2024 i don't think i don't know if
it's 2028 might even be 2032 if you're
lucky
where you're gonna have a president lose
the popular mandate by 10 million votes
and still win the election and that's
the way it's supposed to be
well that's i mean i that
whether it's that's the way it's
supposed to be or not
you're going to have a huge number of
people in your country who don't regard
themselves as living in a legitimate
democracy and so
right never have been okay well i i mean
you did call yourself the world's
greatest democracy for a long time yeah
and until and in 2000 you said we're
going to export democracy to the world
but this is this is this is your house
media establishment politicians who have
no idea what they're talking about well
you know you did call yourself a
democracy for 240 years i mean like
well
like ronald reagan
like i mean like every every american
president i have for sure
democracy so if you're saying you're not
a democracy and and this is part of the
problem so uh there's a reason we have
an electoral college there's a famous
quote from benjamin franklin democracy
is two wolves and a lamb deciding what's
for lunch a republic is a well-armed
lamb contesting the vote
i'll give you i'll give you that's not
that's that's minoritarian but that's
not the same thing as that's minority
protection that's not the same thing as
minoritarian rule i mean that is that is
a very big distinction i mean in canada
we understand this really implicitly
right like we have a minority population
french canadians who are you know who
who have to be protected from the
majority rule by like just to keep the
country together good night and we also
so that's like a very distinct that's a
distinct thing and we also have the
system because there was a period where
california was much like wyoming with no
election power the fact that people
choose to live in in populous states
you actually need a functional control
for that so people don't all just crowd
into one tight space and actually spread
out and that is the system but that's
the opposite of where we're going in
this world i mean other than you who
moved from no no no
we're
we're actually seeing people leave
cities because of the problems yeah well
and well it's probably also covent from
wikipedia it looks like we are
officially a federal presidential
constitutional republic yes so let me
give you an example of uh yeah so you
mentioned minority protections is a good
thing the the example that i expected
but minority protection is different
from minoritarian rule no i love that
that's important so in in in california
when i was covering the drought we went
to fascinating east porterville a small
mostly migrant city with no water why
the the farmers were for were not
allowed to access access to surface
water because of the drought the surface
water had had to be rerouted to cities
why because the cities had voting power
and voted away the water from the people
who actually had it so what happens is
the farmers
being a large portion of the united
states economy said we're gonna have to
drill deeper and deeper into ground
water and they went down thousands even
tens of thousands of feet the small the
small family migrant workers could only
drill about 30 feet and their water went
dry that's chapter three
big cities inequality et cetera well
it's not that so much as the water
problem that the united states faces
yeah i mean
that was the
that was the chapter that kept me up at
night it's funny not any of the no no no
no the politics stuff like it's funny
the one that kept me up was talking to
like an expert at the usda on corn did
you did you uh look into the the lawsuit
attempts to seize great lakes water yeah
well well of course in canada we're
really obsessed with this because like
we have all the water right like we have
one-fifth of the world's natural water
supply and so what happens when you guys
run out of your water is of great
concern to us so there was there was an
attempt by i could be getting this wrong
it's been a while arizona i think was
filing a federal suit right claiming
they had access to great lakes but the
problem for them was the great lakes
coalition includes canada yes so i think
specifically ontario and yeah well and
manitoba as well and manitoba and so
basically they were like we have an
international treaty on this water you
can't that's right and that's really
important to us
important too i'm from chicago right i
mean yeah the thing about lake michigan
for instance is that we were depleting
it because so much water was being
consumed we had to put in environmental
protections to make sure the water
replenished before so we could only take
so much from well i mean the worst thing
to me is the ogallala aquifer which
they're accessing to grow like we live
in an era of completely cheap food like
artificially cheap food largely driven
by midwest the genius of midwestern
farmers who have innovated corn to a
point of you know extreme
productivity and that's dr driven by
this aquifer that is not renewable yeah
like that's just water they're taking
out of the ground that when it's gone
it's gone wow and where they go from
there
they don't really know and like i want
you to imagine a world where we don't
have cheap food anymore
that's that's
added to all this stuff we're talking
about right added to all this all this
conflict like that that's when things
start to get real in a hurry i uh uh i
tweeted this a while ago
in 50 years we are going to look back
and laugh about literally flushing fresh
water down the toilet
well i mean you already have it in
certain places like you know when
when california goes through its
droughts right like you know people
brush their teeth very carefully right
like they you know like it's not like
you know you know you know some people
do some people do something i think most
people don't i was encouraging people to
pee in the sink for a while
[Laughter]
do it no waste that water
no you pee in the top of the toilet so
you can flush with urine oh
that's always a layer yes you can use
that
that's useful
did you ever like um in any of these
like when you were like thinking of all
the potential possibilities did you ever
find out like corporations would get
involved and be like hey we're going to
supply your weapons and help you win
when you give us states when you win
we'll take florida and
no i mean that was not something i
looked at i mean what i looked at was
inequality levels which are of course
like catastrophically high and uh
you know
they there are no examples of history of
countries with inequality rates like the
united states that don't end in war
revolution or mass death like it's like
it's a like it's a they're like you go
like you're literally like i have a lot
of like on the one hand this on the one
hand this in the book right like
some examples go this way some examples
go the other way but when you look at
inequality levels like the ones you have
in the united states they only go one
way this is financial inequality well um
it's it's income inequality is the main
one but the one is it's also the wealth
inequality the wealth gap which is
catastrophic yeah capitals and
these past couple of years oh it's just
exploding people well it tends like it
builds on itself right i mean that's the
thing about capital it builds on its
part it might be a problem is that you
give money to your kids i like it i mean
it's always been normal but like it's
making stupid rich people like kids that
aren't qualified for the money are
growing up with it and has power well as
i say like i i try not to judge anyone
like i'm not like not every time i'm
looking at structures here but what i do
know is that when you get to inequality
levels with this kind of structural
problem it just creates huge amounts of
turbulence obviously you've pointed out
problems have you thought of any
solutions
well i mean
much like him here like i'm not sure i
see uh i mean so don't judge me
well i'm not i'd like to i think i think
i think my strength
in this book is that i'm not on either
side of this so i don't really i
disagree
well i want stability i think i think
you are on the the left side
well
i guess maybe but you know i would say
that i kind of tried to consciously work
against that like obviously i'm a
canadian i believe in socialized
medicine and gun control but the
conservative party believes in that
right like like so it's
i definitely don't feel affiliated with
the democratic tribe right like and i
don't and i don't feel like like when
you mention biden like i haven't you
know he means nothing to me but the
truckers
oh you want to do the truckers now eh oh
sure you know i don't know well i i i
finally got your first a in thank you
it's been all evening did i say yes you
did
finally
i was waiting for it yeah well i
actually say it a lot so so the the just
just to start this off yeah
the same people who supported
occupational protest with occupy wall
street and the occupant and the jazz
yeah and and the uh i would never
support any of those and canada would
support any of those but um in america
these same people are now in at odds and
in defiance with these people if i can
be honest with you like when i hear the
debate here about the trucker convoy it
is it's like have you ever seen like a
movie where you know what really
happened
and like you see the movie and you're
like it has nothing to do with like it's
just so distorted that it has nothing to
do with reality like that when i the the
largest support for the trucker convoy
i've seen in my life was driving here
in maryland and someone had a big sign
up right i mean you have to remember
like here it's become
like all this stuff about trudeau and
you know all this like the person who
did the
the original emergencies act was doug
ford the premier of ontario who's a
populist conservative and i i personally
have called him a tin pot northern trump
in the pages of the new york times he
was like this is this is a very the
political context of this in canada is
just completely separate from the
political context here like it's it's
just it's just a completely different
framework of interpretation of events
and
you know
we get our news about it from canadians
well
they're coming to talk to you right now
like you watch we watch people on the
ground who are reporting they're on the
ground talking with interviewing people
well yes but they're sending the sites
to american news sources like if you
look at the if you look at the america
if you look at the globe and mail fry is
a is a canadian lawyer live streaming it
right so i just turn on his stream and
we just watch what he's talking about
right he's not the only source we use
so for the most i would just say the
reporting that i've seen in american
sources from both sides
like it has really like i was trying to
i was trying to think like how could i
explain this and i was like well you
know the quebec premier
who
is a conservative like he's he's
definitely the right um a month ago
proposed a tax on the unvaccinated right
like just a straight tax
this is a different world than the world
you guys are in you know what i mean
like
like because of universal health care
well we have that too though like like
uh dc had a vax mandate you couldn't go
inside buildings attacks did any
american politician suggest you know
what if you don't get a vaccine you're
going to have to pay a levy no they gave
people free money
but i think it's not even going to get
it just
we're going to
i want you to imagine an american
conservative politician
saying we're going to tax people for not
getting vaccinations what we saw was um
i got to put this back up here oh yeah
yeah sure
what what we have that everyone's
actually going to listen to big big
organizations um hospitals and uh
corporations
saying if you don't get vaccinated we're
deducting we're slashing your pay but
see you're firing you yeah or firing you
universal healthcare just completely
changes the dynamic of all of these
questions right and that's why
like canadian anger at the truckers is
so profound and so
wide like you know why 70 percent of
canadians want to call in the military
right and like 70 70 like these are
people with kids right like and you know
like 90 of canadians want them gone
right like
the the reason for that is like
when you're in a universal healthcare
system
uh
they're when they get sick
it costs me money
it's a burden on the taxpayer right and
like when they get sick it takes a space
like my cousin cam who's got problems
with his heart and needs surgery like
when they're sick
they when they're filling up the
hospitals he can't get the treatment
that he needs i have a question did you
did they distribute vaccines in the
basis of race in canada
uh yeah well there was a they went to
indigenous populations first because
they were uh
they were more vulnerable to the disease
so they they did go but those are you
know very those are remote communities i
had a friend like that's an affront to
no i don't think so no for our values
right no but
they're more they're more vulnerable
like those those they it went to
vulnerable communities first that's very
racist experimenting no no it's like no
no quite literally in the united states
to claim that a certain person of a
certain races has different
susceptibilities or different traits
based on race is over i think sickle
cell anemia was endemic to the
african-american pop that's racism well
in in america
i guess i i mean
so so it's i don't know like those
that's the why i wouldn't i wouldn't say
it as contradictory no the united states
it is yeah well what i'm saying is that
the the canadian
facts on the ground are just totally
separate not for sure from the from the
debate that you guys are having the
debate you guys are and i mean
like another thing is like you know less
than 30 percent of the fundraising for
this group came from canadian sources i
actually uh read that wasn't true
well there's different it really depends
on how you read the numbers but it's
it's definitely the majority of the
funding came from american sources the
only the only source i've the give sengo
that's that's the give send go the only
sources i've seen on are that the
majority was actually canadian sources
no i i've i have completely different
sources i mean you know
it's a six it's a nine yeah you guys are
both who knows it's the same yeah well i
mean i i i certainly uh well you can
look it up well the pro the problem is
there's no way to look it up if i know
isn't that the truth if i type in
canadians funded i know i'll find all
the sources yeah everything if i type in
americans did it i'll find all the
sources yeah yeah i know so i'm like i
don't even know what to search for but
like i would just say like it's
when i see the american debater like
i've ne i've yet to see an
american left-wing source
say that the number one enemy of the
truckers is rob ford's brother
right like that like swing source like
yeah like msnbc it's become this debate
around justin trudeau or whatever
but like the point is like the
conservatives have all said go home
the like the the the the like he is the
most conservative he's also the most
powerful conservative in canada if i
were gambling i would say he'd be our
next conservative prime minister
um
like he and i think i think this might
make him the next conservative prime
minister uh like he he's very active in
this right so
no one no one seems capable of
mentioning that i'll tell you you know
what i got a prediction here's what's
gonna happen when the civil war breaks
out in the united states we annex canada
first thing
i want to do a tv show about it
i really i've honestly had i've i've
because i've asked myself the question
what would an how would an occupied
canada act
how would you like would they would they
would we resist because you know like
we're talking here like if i were to
tell you i was an american you would
believe me
right i would yeah we would believe you
yeah right like
like so it would create what kind of
occupation would it be let me tell you
i'll tell you exactly you have ideas
i know exactly how to happen so imagine
now it's one year after the occupation
um all the canadians are dancing in the
street in their cars throwing money in
the air they all got gold chains
everyone owns a lamborghini they're all
rich and successful and they're like man
this freedom stuff worked out way better
than our crappy government
water that's pretty funny
i think american u.s should get together
well here's the thing what i what i
really wonder about it is
what if they if they made every province
a state
so that would be let's say 10 provinces
a state that would make the america way
left-wing well wasn't there suddenly
suddenly overnight america would be a
left-wing wasn't there
a country that would you know like over
like it would be really wasn't there a
belief back in the 80s or 90s when
quebec was doing its like much stronger
separatist movement that northwest
territories would try to apply for
american statehood giving us a direct
road to canada there was albertans out
there yeah they had the oil there was
well i mean there was a lot of chaos
there was a lot of crazy thinking out
there but you know you also had your
civil war
i mean
so
there's martial law declared in my
country now like if the government wants
to seize my bank accounts they don't
need a court order that's crazy right
like still
in 1970 when they had when they declared
martial law they arrested people that
you didn't need a warrant to arrest
anyone my country's nearly died twice in
my lifetime 1982 and 1995. this is not a
book of judgment this is a book of like
what's amazing to me what's the most
shocking thing maybe one of the most
shocking things that's happened in my
life is that somehow canada has become
the stable country and america has
become the unstable country i mean if
you told me that that would happen when
i was 20 yeah
everyone would have laughed in your face
i i think it's uh in all seriousness i
do think canada gets involved in
whatever civil war happens in the united
states oh we're
i mean we're in trouble like you're well
this the trucker convoy is already your
political proxy it's a political proxy
conflict
on our soil of your
toxic discourse
i don't think it's our toxic discourse i
think it's it's it's the uk has been
experiencing this canada's been
experiencing it the u.s but canada is
canada has resisted it in a lot of ways
because of
because of a bunch of really odd
policies like we have very strict
immigration but we are very
pro-immigration and we have we have uh
we didn't 2008 didn't happen to us right
like we didn't we didn't have occupy
wall street because we are because we're
so vulnerable we because we're not
america like we we had to protect our
banks and our banks came through very
safe well what america is the tip of the
spirit it's the center of the empire
exactly
montreal says of the most uh culturally
diverse city in toronto toronto toronto
is more than half
except i'm pretty foreign toronto is
majority white
um
no i mean
the thing that's funny is like canada
has multicultural policy even though
we're about seven well i'm sure toronto
is multi is majority way it's just half
foreign born yeah uh but um you know
toronto you know canada is about 78 way
and yeah whereas the united states is 58
so it's you know there's there's a
there's quite a gap there too
47.9 the is the plurality the plurality
is is white
um the plurality so it is not a majority
white city that's it is not majority
white interesting well that makes sense
yeah which is interesting yeah
yeah that's very different policies over
in canada compared to well we're
bringing in 400 000 immigrants next year
right and that's in a country of 40
million
in canada the more patriotic you are the
more in favor of immigration you are i
think that's a that's a huge difference
and i think you you were talking about
abortion and how you think it's a
polarizing issue and it is i think
should the civil war come
those who are not here legally should be
the one who are most concerned because
there are parts of this country that
they will ask for your papers
and you will flee to california or
illinois or new york well already in
2016
there was a flood of people across the
border you know how many in a civil war
people would flood the borders that
aren't natural that would fight for a
side to get their citizenship like you'd
have
millions
of foreign oh like my great great
grandfather who was irish who fought for
the north because he wanted to be an
american except ian in new york now
you can vote he's a non-citizen so
they're going to just go to the state
and be like we're here anyway and then
that's it
so i you know that point i made about
taxes and geography before i think one
thing you might end up seeing the map
you have in your book yeah might
actually be an accurate starting point
yeah i mean it's it's very much states
will align based yeah i mean it's like a
that's that's like you know a bar room
suggestion like obviously it's not it's
not like how it would actually i think
uh interestingly
i would i'd be willing to bet new
hampshire
at this point would declare independence
in any conflict well that's another
possibility because they're from the
freestanders right yeah well there and
well and also vermont there's a huge
separatist movement in vermont that's
very serious and well i mean they're not
as serious as texas but they'll get
occupied very quickly
you know
do people want to occupy countries
anymore no like what would be the value
in occupying new hampshire like that's
access
to what to maple syrup to other states
that are part of your union i guess i
mean military i don't really go there
like you know like the the the
i would assume that what would happen is
that there'd be
um
the attempt to control like it would be
the the civil war that i envisioned
would not be really between sides it
would be between the forces of order and
chaos people would try right it would be
between people who want disorder and
want breakdown and people who are trying
to keep the institutions alive by by
force and like and of course the problem
is as america has learned in its
counterinsurgency strategy and as you
know i talked to
an anonymous colonel who is responsible
for drawing up what they call full
spectrum operations in the homeland like
the more you try to control a population
militarily that just spreads violence
you know you know i think you're right
about that point about ordering chaos
but my vision of it is
the democratic establishment the which
used to be the democrat republican like
uniparty until donald trump came in then
you ended up with these neocons joining
the democrats like bill crystal the
lincoln project people the democrats
saw these far left individuals these
progressives as a way to bolster their
ranks and get votes essentially the one
ring they thought they could wield the
power but they can't because the woke
the cancel culture stuff the the far
left they are a chaotic and destructive
force but the it's also that the
institutions themselves are rotting from
the center right like
it's not just a question of like the
partisanship it's a question of like
is the senate a functional body no no
right like it isn't like it's not it's
not a functioning body you should you
should
you're in a government where supposedly
has control of all three levels of like
how and they can't pass basic policies
like well people don't know what agrees
on them well exactly and they can't win
like they can't like in in canadian
parliament british parliamentary system
when you control the system you make the
decisions and then you were responsible
for them do you know how it used to work
this way you know how congress works so
we had uh marjorie taylor green on yeah
and she said
when she went to congress she was
confused because she's sitting there and
there's like 10 democrats or like five
democrats and like five republicans and
there's some random guy she doesn't know
at the speaker's podium pulls up a bill
and goes bill assembly bill you know you
know congressional bill 473 in favor
democrats and they go
republicans no democrats have it next
bill and she was like wait no one's even
voting on this stuff right so she called
a roll call vote which forced all the
members of congress back to actually
record their votes they must have hated
her and they they come after her for it
and that's probably why you hear these
insane stories about her in the press
because she's in defiance of none of
these people want to work so we had
thomas massey on well you know what
their job is i mean you know fundraising
their job is fundraising exactly i mean
when you actually talk to i've been
interviewing a politician lately about
the inner workings of uh
electoral politics for a possible sequel
to this book and
you know it's staggering like like when
i i had like a 20-minute conversation
with this guy and i was like oh well no
wonder this system is so screwed up like
all all they think all they can think
about all day is the three levels of
fundraising dark money
social media money and bundle money
that's that's what that's what they do
all day that's a big problem
it is a it is it is non-functional like
it is a non-functioning system
and we need to go to super chats so we
did a little bit of longer longer shows
today because you know typically what we
do with um the members only segment is
we'll save like a spicier story for a
timecast.com
segment but i figured because we're
going to be having kind of an amorphous
conversation about civil war in politics
it wouldn't really work out to do that
so i just we extended the normal show
now we'll go to super chats and uh his
mail has already
started just for warning
there's a lot of canadians and they're
like truckers no well i mean you know
let's uh let's read this this is
actually a good question yeah wrestler
town says if mr marsh started writing
his book five years ago i'd like to know
which right-wing activists he had to
compare to the left at the conception of
his book his go-to january 6 example
happened one year ago
well um it was certain like the what
inspired it was the trump inauguration
and the general atmosphere of violence i
mean i wouldn't say at the beginning of
it i was like um i mean i went and
talked to various prepper groups i went
to talk to various far-right groups um i
i talked to richard spencer i talked to
uh like various members of the far right
and going and meeting them in ohio and
like you know in the field research so
that's different than i would say i can
icons or something like that um
and i just you know i got along very
well with them and uh they
and also like you know sons of
confederate veterans and things like
this like uh you know um
and and sovereign citizens and
constitutional sheriffs and uh sagebrush
rebels and so yeah i would talk to all
these different groups uh now you know
like the the specific violence that
they're involved in is sometimes purely
in their own minds right and sometimes
the right wing groups
i mean you go and meet these guys and
sometimes it's like
this is a hobby
this is like thinking about the civil
war it's like it's like am i am i with a
far-right group who's plotting the
overthrow of the us government or are
these basically like bird watchers then
how do you compare them to the two
billion dollars and that's that's the
insurance maximum we think the damage
from the george floyd riots was actually
higher than that
well there's a lot there's lots of
violence on all sides here i mean surely
there's not sure
well i mean all i can like you can read
the book and check my sources but those
are the sources that i have they come
from foreign they come from foreign
sources they come they're not democratic
or republican there's there's no lack of
right-wing violence in this country but
there's certainly
substantially more coming from the
latter i would not say that that my
evidence would say the opposite so there
was there was uh uh
millions of dollars in damage well
that's property damage i mean it depends
i guess i i don't i don't think i
destroyed i don't think i have 30 30
people dead well i was dealing with
murders right yeah i don't think i don't
think i think 26 of those were murders
i don't i didn't i never did a compare
comparative analysis of property value
damage um
i guess i probably should have done that
well but but like i um
i i just went with the murder rates but
this because that seems to me because
the murder rates are where you get
closer to that's where you get close to
the definition of civil war i i just i i
i guess technically but i disagree i
mean if you've got a mass movement
funded by corporations that advocates
and and the vice president herself is is
is providing bail for people who are
burning down buildings and smashing
windows and killing people like we're
there man
like look look kamala harris well donald
trump saying what you know how about the
republican party saying january 6 is
legitimate political discourse what was
the specific context around that well i
don't know but like
then i don't think you have a point well
i would just say that there's certainly
been legitimization of violence on the
right like
i don't really think that's debatable
you got to give me a specific example
because i can name january 6. january
sex is one thing that happened one time
and i can give you over the past several
years i mean the french revolution is
one thing that happened one time
we're talking about 800 people of which
several hundred uh fought their way to
the front tunnel entrance and the other
several hundred walked through the back
door that was opened by police but i can
also go back to like well there's
a state the organs the organ uh mike
nearman when he when he let in the the
rioters who i mean
nothing happened there
they opened the door and the guy got in
trouble i can talk about the vandalism
of the legislature
i went to the ice facility with with uh
with an ar and fire bombed it we had uh
the guy aaron danielson gets shot and
killed we had new we had over 800
instances of low tier what i called
violence i mean you've like this is
something that has been repeated in this
conversation you say show me an example
then i do
and then you say keep saying january 6th
well that's a pretty big one man but
that's the only one i mean like it
happened well there's no way to go well
after a decade of political violence
from the left well would you consider
sovereign citizenship to be right-wing
violence because certainly the the
groups that i do do on what scale are
these guys about 50 murders a year and
and those are murders based on people
killing cops at tr traffic stops so
as i said there are there are
definitional questions here like i'm not
i'm not trying to hide anything but
certainly that would like you would
probably not consider that a far-right
group you probably you might just
consider those criminals what what what
makes them right-wing
uh they believe in no taxes they believe
in a dim they come from small government
ideology of they be they believe in the
rejection of the 14th amendment um they
that's their they come from they they
come from so they they're they're the
roots of q and on mentality that's been
stewards
so far separated
how does that relate to a trump
supporter well we're not in the realm
well they're roughly on the same spec i
mean when you're dealing with the far
right in the united states you're
dealing with a a huge collection of
ideas that are not coherently connected
but black lives matter is and they march
together
and it also
strips itself apart very quickly and and
is also filled with a lot of
segmentation so like like i mean there's
no like i i would say
all i'm saying here is you know you
would
you you would say that your right wing
does not commit any violence i don't say
that but there well there's some
violence but if you're looking at like
mass terms of violence like you have to
look at things like sovereign citizens
or q and on or you know et cetera like
th
it would just not be reasonable to say
that those are not but right-wing
political violence this is why i
explained in the beginning that the
right engages what i define as sharp
acute instances and the left is well
let's go let's stay with that because
like that seems to me quite correct but
one substantially worse
right i don't believe that i believe
that i believe that well it depends
let me explain so the sovereign citizens
in the united states are not a distilled
destabilizing factor they absolutely are
i mean the fbi declared them the number
one threat to police to police yeah but
because they're honest
the fbi goes and sends 12 agents to a
garage pole rope
well you know this is the thing where
i'm a canadian and i'm an outsider so to
me when you when you're against the fbi
like that's where
the americans have not had a good
relationship with the fbi well no one
has a good relationship with the police
forces of their country well no police
versus need reform the i's got is called
what's the administrative state or deep
state j edgar hoover was like yeah i'm a
canadian so you know the motto of canada
like the amount of america's life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness the
motto of canada is peace order and good
government the money of america is in
god we trust what i find with peace
peace and order is you can have a slave
state that suppressed its population
into peace and order and they're not
they're still slaves and unhappy but
there's peace
so i think uh
a good a good example of the breakdown
um and there's no middle ground right so
well that's it the middle ground is gone
everybody in the chat perceives you as
far left
right i mean but in my own country that
would just be so ludicrous well no but
far left doesn't mean like you refer to
certain people as far right far left
it's me
they're world view signifiers so yeah
that's a fair point i mean i would say
i'm talking about a specific category
about all of those i'll i'll tell you
you know like i'm doing research and uh
i come across a story about a guy no one
says name seriously and uh because if
you do youtube will shut the show down
constantly yeah that is there's nothing
uh
on the left so i sit down with jack
dorsey and we pull up a tweet of an
antifa account overtly calling for
organizing and inciting violence and
giving instructions on what to do and
they went well
there's lots of evidence of right wing
radicalization through social media
networks like
lots of it sure sure my point is i mean
the algorithms the algorithms point to
extremism
of both kinds
so uh
the data actually shows because i've
covered this for years uh a flow towards
the left this is it's it's it's but
we've actually had there's a researcher
who mapped out all of political youtube
and found it flows two to one to the
left
and and this is easily exemplified by
the fact that right-wing channels get
banned all the time and left-wing
channels don't they get propped up and
they get mainstream media coverage
i i i have no evidence of that so like
steven crowder for instance is he's a
he's a mainstream conservative he gets
strike strike strike strike strike and
then he has to go on hiatus to let the
strikes roll off his channel he gets
forced onto rumble meanwhile you have
anti-foot channels they don't left-wing
political channels they don't experience
the same thing uh on on twitter but the
top ten people on facebook are all
right-wing groups right wait when guys
venture peers in this world and facebook
is predominantly older you know boomer
and stuff like that well so what i mean
people eyeballs their eyeballs i mean
those are the pointers
like that you you have to understand
i've gone across this country i've
talked to people from both sides you all
say they're both very different but that
means you have their doctor that means
you haven't done the fact because i
haven't come to your side no i'm not i
don't
know
see i don't think you understand right
the the right calls us liberals
trump supporters call us liberals ian is
a weird hippie communist something or
other authoritarian and we had a
libertarian and i'm in favor i'm in
favor of universal basic health care
right i support progressive taxes yeah
but in this country the left will call
me right wing and the right will call me
left-wing well i'm i'm you know honestly
i'm kind of in the same position right
like your your group is calling me far
left but like when i was an esquire
columnist for years i was considered
like norman mailer and i and like
constantly called out for all these kind
of questions but then like like here's
my point though sorry because no go
ahead finish because i also we got to do
super chats the the main issue was when
you cite the fbi
it's a signal to these people you
haven't done any research into the fbi
and so yeah i've interviewed a lot of
fbi agents but you haven't done the fact
checking so like when the new york times
lies and makes up fake crap and then we
have to fact check it and prove it wrong
with evidence this book is deeply
fact-checked this this is why i used the
deeply i mean i'm i i don't i have a lot
of failings i have a lot of a lot of
stuff to be humble for
but this book is correct so this but
this is why i use the joe biden ukraine
gate as a really good example
because if you go to the new york times
and ask them did joe biden quid pro coil
they'll say no and that's factually
incorrect
all evidence points the fact that joe
biden did this he's even on video saying
he did it and for some reason
so when the fbi doesn't prosecute
hillary clinton doesn't prosecute joe
biden or even investigate these things
when you have the collusion between
twitter and facebook shutting down the
story about hunter biden's laptop when
hunter biden is is publicly known to
have illegally acquired a handgun or
disposed of one nothing happens oh no
they reported on all that no no i'm
saying the fbi hasn't done anything oh
well i mean
you know the number like everyone always
says that about crime and the thing but
the time is like tiny only tiny little
amounts
the dhs specifically comes out and says
it's effectively the right that is the
problem without talking about blm and
the billions of dam and dozen damage
people say they have no credibility if
you cite them they'll say well one side
says that they have no credibility i
mean the problem we're in is the one we
keep going back to which is like
the sides are so divided now that like
literally there is no common ground in
fact there is no common ground in
narrative there is no common ground like
in language in institutions there was no
common ground in language exactly right
and like when you're in that condition
you either have to find a way back to
that common ground or split up you're
not far left right i mean like this is
it like you either have to work towards
let's find a way to talk together or you
have to say it's done you're not far
left and it's unfair to say you are far
left far left i mean no no for anyone to
say you are because the reason why
you're not far left is because you're
here because they're real far left in
america and people may say they're real
far well you may understand what desire
to sell
they would not sit together and have
this conversation and that is one of the
biggest problems i mean i do political
debate for a living even though i have
been very taciturn this evening yeah um
but it is hard to find an open-minded
and i'm sure they would say the same
about us but we don't sit together
crossfire is gone right yes we don't sit
together and have these no intellectual
conversations yeah we have four
panelists who think the way we do on our
program and they who can screen the labs
exactly and that's and that's the
political district so i i i do think
you know some of these super chats are
making points that we've probably
already made and it's probably not
relevant to make but i do want to read
them anyway madison says easy experiment
wear a maga hat at a leftist event wear
a blm hat at a right event you'll see
who talks and who uses violence very
clearly the
left uh
blair white for example wore a maga hat
around hollywood and got physically
assaulted i mean you i i've been to i
went to uh in one example i used boston
i don't i mean
those those kind of experiments to me
have so little value they
don't they don't mean it they don't mean
anything i went to a rally in boston the
right came with shields the left came
with clubs and bats
and
there's lots of clubs and bats on the
other everyone has clubs and bats these
days i think it's
yes exactly i want you to survive please
survive like that that's my as your
neighbor as your friend and neighbor
please survive and the only way you're
going to survive is by either finding
some way to get into common language or
to or to break up i think science let me
let me just got to read more of these
mike says a major pipeline project in
canada was attacked by 20 masked
individuals with axes and flare guns
deep in the woods this morning millions
in property damage destroyed heavy
equipment and work camp media silent
well
the left would take that because like
all of the indigenous protests about
pipelines got broken up very quickly and
and quite aggressively and like for you
know like the ottawa police were sued
for
16 million successfully for their um
for their brutality over the g7
the leftist protest so actually i think
i mean this is that's a canadian example
so it's actually not very relevant but
you know
one of the things is like there are many
people on the left asking like well
if these were left-wing protesters in
ottawa would they be treated anywhere
near as decently as they have been so
far like there there's a lot there's a
lot of
i i and i and i i frankly i sympathize
with that
we have this super chat from uh
legema the gay and i'm probably pouncing
that wrong all the time he says right
right-wing esoteric knowledge like q
anon is crazy but is less insane and far
less dangerous mainstream and
institutionally entrenched compared to
standard progressive dogma it's
ridiculous to make an equation between
the two
i mean i do find that interesting that's
not in my book and i find it one of the
more fascinating things that i didn't
answer like there are a few like
mysteries that were kind of around the
edges of the book that i because i tried
to be really specific and like really
only say what i know
but like the the the fascination with
esoteric knowledge on the right i i just
find it fascinating there was a uh are
you familiar with the uh you're probably
canadian the indefinite detention
provision of the national defense
authorization act no i don't know that
although it should what is that so in i
think it was 2012 barack obama signed
into law in our national defense
authorization act reauthorizes you know
spending on national defense and stuff
and obama uh signed into it he was like
oh no i can't believe they're doing this
but it was everybody you know the unit
party puts it in it allows the us to
detain anyone anywhere in the world for
any reason at any time and hold them
wherever they want right and so dave
smith was uh
telling a story uh on joe rogan's
podcast where he said
brian stelter was complaining that
conspiracy theory videos about how you
know certain tragic events didn't really
happen were dangerous
and you know dave's point was like if
some weirdo guy makes a youtube video
it's like sure it's annoying and brian's
shelter's like no it's dangerous and he
goes you know what's dangerous that
barack obama signed into law the
indefinite detention provision of the
national defense authorization act and
the media didn't cover it
yeah i mean
i i think there's so much that's
dangerous right now like you know when i
called it a complex cascading system
yeah these things all feed into each
other you know like one of the
one of the things that i think is
happening that's you know probably i
shouldn't have brought up right at the
end of this conversation is like
people's sense of what is real is
fraying
right like they don't know what is real
like that's part of the esoteric
information they don't they lose faith
in institutions but they're also like
what is actually happening is very hard
to tell
and i think that's and and i think
that's part of the contribution to this
chaos is that they're like what was the
used term you used semantics what was it
you had a really good way of phrasing it
i thought i'll look at the tape later
argument no it's semantic carnage or
something i forget what it was i don't
think that was me i think you said that
no no no it was you i said it oh you did
what was it no i'm just taking credit
for someone made a good point i was
going to take it say it in the chat you
guys you know bandit corruption or i
forget what it was but it was that love
of esoteric and knowledge that's kind of
what god is and it seems like that
resonates with people on the right i
don't think of people on the right or
left much like that i ian seems like
religion one of the four components of
religion is to proselytize and spread
your religion
not to hold it within it
the kind of religion in american life is
actually a huge part and if people are
like reaching for some sort of knowledge
that they can latch onto and that's q or
whatever it is i i think exactly and i
think you get the sense of meaning that
you got from church you get in politics
now and it's wow that's super i want to
i want to yeah and that's very dangerous
i want to address a lot of these super
chats yeah because i think you know one
of the things i was making earlier the
point i made earlier on is that we agree
on a lot of the core issues that's
happening yeah but we probably we
disagree on like that well i think you
have a perspective and my perspective is
30 000 feet in the air that's what i
would like to say a lot of people are
commenting like oh he's wrong about this
he's wrong about that yeah you know and
he's wrong about no i think i think
stephen is very much correct about civil
war i think there's probably core
political issues that we have different
views on but like that's why i thought
it was but i don't know i mean i think
when you actually like you're in favor
of universal healthcare you're in favor
of progressive taxation i mean the
problem that we're dealing with here is
that when you talk about politics we've
had this paul this whole this we talked
for like two and a half hours now about
politics policy has been
five minutes ten minutes like actual
policies but let me let me explain i can
back up everything i claim with a source
that is
like effectively academic and mainstream
certified
and uh
and i'm a civil libertarian my views are
are on you know freedom of the
individual the decentralization is
typically how i put it i don't like the
idea that you get one despot who thinks
he knows everything we've seen how that
goes
but the problem is
i've been on the ground at all of these
protests i spend my start of my career
going to different protests and talking
to people and what did i find when i
would go to like a right-wing event they
would be very specific to the to the
point of like this is my thing this is
my thing and so like a trump rally
they'd say
my factory closed down trump wants to
bring factories back and end free trade
right i'd go to left-wing rallies and
they'd say i don't know
see i had this experience when i was in
2015 where i covered the canadian
election
and then i went down and covered a trump
rally in a sanders rally like right
right after each other they're both in
iowa within three days of each other and
so
this is what a canadian debate is like
sir we need to spend 428 million on
education you're completely wrong we
need to spend 485 million dollars on
education it's all numbers and it's all
boring technical policy things i mean
it's unwatchably boring then you go to
america and it's god
and socialism
these grand ideas that have no practical
applications that are incredibly vague
and have and and have like a and just
simply are essentially aesthetic
categories here here and like when we
talk like what we're talking about here
is language
it's
but if you were to actually see like i
think the abortion question comes up
here again where it's like the like if
you were to actually sit down like what
what are our policy objectives we want
women to be in control of their bodies
and we want abortion rates to decline
guess what guess what there's a really
good way to do that but you're wrong
that's right i'm wrong because that's
not what they want no they want no
abortion at all right well
if you want to get well that's not ever
going to happen it will by force or by
decree the united states cannot control
the flow of heroin onto its streets the
idea that's going to control a major
surgical procedure that you can get
chemically you don't got to look at it
so absolutely the idea among the
pro-life well that's my point you don't
have to look at absolutely shut down the
abortion clinics and end the government
sanction of murder right that's their
view that's their view and that is a
essentially a religious view whereas if
they're if they're if their views were
policy based if they were like well how
is that not policy-based because if you
the policy is asked what is the end
we're looking for collectively winning
the government support of murder but see
that's
that's not a policy that's a vision you
know what do you mean like a policy is
like we want a result the result we want
is fewer abortions and if you want the
if you want the result we want is the
government to stop supporting abortions
that's that's again you're an aesthetic
you're you're in an aesthetic political
category you're like you're asking large
questions about what your government is
who you are what you are as a people put
aside those questions ask what do you
want they want the government to stop
actively supporting well i see that's
right and see i would never like i would
say
that you know in sensible countries what
you ask is what do you want to do here
like what do you actually want to
achieve if you want to achieve lower
abortion rates there are many many ways
to do that criminalization would not be
among them but i i think this is your
bias right well i think my bias is pro
policy like what i believe is that
government is an agent
there certainly is uh uh
like hey we we live in a country and the
country takes x position we would like
the government to stop taking that
position it's that simple yeah and see
that's to me is the least interesting
question of politics is the question of
like what is the government exactly like
what does the crowd understand the
question will still exist they just say
like here's the line we want to set
that's right
it's a moral question of their own
identity of who they are as and who
their government is and that's you know
that that is the thing about america
it's like you have this idea of
yourselves as a shining city on a hill
as a as a beacon for the world whereas i
think in other countries that are
perhaps more stable it's like well what
are we doing here
how can we make life a little bit better
how can we make it how can we make it
how can we make things
we're in these systems how can we make
these systems better and like when you
get to the systems questions when you
get to those policy questions there's
actually a lot of common ground there's
actually it's easy it's it's actually
quite possible to build things together
i agree we have another super chat yeah
sorry i've gone too long about this no
but but i agree on that we probably
agree a lot of things in there but we
have a good this is a good super chat
seth hauser says there are no two
versions of america it has always been a
constitutional republic formed by the
founding fathers
it's actually a really good point when
you said that there's a multicultural
democracy in a constitutional republic
what you're
this country has always been a
constitutional republic albeit with
politicians making improper statements
about being a democracy or whatever
or like for 240 years uh sure i mean
okay the fact but the founding fathers
had arguments about over federalism and
what the republic was using this in the
first civil war wrote about what the
republic was they didn't call it
democracy benjamin franklin has comments
about democracy about we're not a
democracy and why we're not a democracy
but the point is that's not what madison
said but anyway for sure but but the
point is if this country was formed as
a constitutional republic
and we now have an emergent
multicultural democracy no no i i don't
think that would be accurate to say that
it's emergent i mean it is in place but
that has been in place for at least
since 1860.
i'll tell you what the real government
is right now is google well that's the
other question yeah i mean that and that
isn't that is another aspect of the book
did they the first civil war
when you go back to the original
founding father documents there's
immense contradiction built into them
right right i i think it was more never
ended well also you could say it began
at the beginning of the country it began
with the three-fifths compromise it
began with the it began with all the
compromises that were embedded in the
constitution that
ultimately were between slave and free
states that were not
subject to compromise did you did you
read about the i think it was the 1872
election in the united states 1876 76
yeah yeah i always mix it up where they
basically were like we'll just
rubber stamp you know and negotiate well
i mean you know one of the subjects of
this book is what an american occupation
would look like and of course 1876 was
the end of the first american occupation
which was the north's occupation of the
south which was
a low-level civil conflict right with
lots of terrorist groups and lots of
and lots of conflict and basically 1876
was
you know the thing is occupation doesn't
never works right like it it's simply
never you can't you can't really occupy
people against their will it just is not
feasible i don't know 20 years in
afghanistan i think proves you did wrong
the settlers
the north american settlers i mean when
you read like the one of the guys i
interview for the book is guy named
daniel bulger who's a real expert in
counter insurgency and no and you know
saw it in iraq and saw it everywhere and
um he's like you know there are
basically no examples of this work but
when you read his book you keep waiting
for the this book is called why we lost
you keep waiting for the losses yeah
like they never they never they don't
lose at all they win everything doesn't
matter yeah it makes no difference i
think if we were doing war gaming of
your book which we're not gonna do
because we'll go back to super chats i
think the the most important variable
is who is what party what faction uh is
the president at this time
and that would be the military and that
would be fast i think the civil war the
american civil war i think would have
been very differently it would have been
very different if if there was a
different president of a different party
and so who controls dc who controls the
military who controls the powers of the
federal government i think we'll will
determine an awful lot again if we were
playing war gaming yeah i mean i worked
on this assumption in the book that the
military oath would hold because
it does it does seem to me like it would
i i've not like it was taken extremely
extremely seriously the military i mean
one of the problems here is that the
military is the last institution with
widespread respect why sorry widespread
respect in the united states which is
not healthy right like that's not
when that's you when that's the back the
backdrop like that's not good but um you
know the the generals in the washington
post a few months ago openly discussed
like with the military fragment
in the case of a contested electoral
college vote that's a that's a whole
level of terror that i didn't put in the
book but it seems to me entirely
plausible
so uh we have this one from babec he
says hi i am 20. and throughout high
school my teachers told me the party's
switched and that dems are not trying to
take your guns the left lies to children
when i was a child i will not compromise
i think i thought this was a a a good
comment one one thing that i think is
apparent to a lot of people if you pay
attention is that
the democratic establishment makes
demands the republican establishment
says no wait don't and so gun control is
a really good example uh the second yeah
one's progressive and one's reactionary
i mean that seems that seems exactly the
pattern yeah so there's no one actually
fighting for
the this is why trump comes around yeah
even though he was in favor of gun
control and banned bump stocks which was
an insane and absurd policy that ruled
by decree but uh
when people on the right say the second
amendment says the right to keep in bear
arms shall not be infringed the
democrats ban guns seize guns arrest
people for guns and the republicans say
slow down there democrats
this results in the trump phenomenon
people finally phenom on people finally
being like i can't take it i don't care
give me the human molotov cocktail i'm
done with this well that i mean
and there's going to be that on the left
too right like that like
that's what we were saying well that's
what we were saying before like the best
way to think of trump is as a symptom
yeah like i mean i think that's
the the when i go and talk to like npr
people and so on i wonder if i'm the
only person that's here to talk to you
and in pr at the same time but uh
possible but like the the part they find
controversial is
um that i say if hillary clinton had
been elected all of this would be
exactly the same
right like the the the the trump like
what we're dealing with here are deep
seated structural problems
that are built into the they are they
transcend completely
the outcomes of elections this is why i
i can't stand the trump fraud narrative
that here i'll give you a funny example
i have never once stated that donald
trump won the 2020 election right nor
that there was widespread fraud that
would have changed in fact quite the
opposite my first reaction when i
started hearing this was i was like dude
i'm not i'm not playing the same game
the same game where hillary clinton came
out and claimed russia and also other
garbage time to be fake
then they said we're gonna do audits
they did audits they didn't come out
with anything substantive and the
company shuts down people are like tim
look at all the data i looked at all the
data there's some interesting stuff
there but ultimately here we are it's
2022 and you know the issue for me is
are we going to keep playing this back
and forth you are
i mean absolutely i think
it just it just the country just rips
apart if that's what we keep doing we
have to change course but i'll tell you
the funny thing
there are organizations right now
that there's an organization that has uh
raised tens of thousands of dollars off
of the lie that i am a proponent of
trump's fraud right even though it's 100
fake
you'll get news outlets lying about my
views oh man i'll give you a great
example they take clips of me they take
clips of joe rogan there's a really
great post i can't remember who put it
up i think it was a zed jelani we've had
him on as a guest several times he said
in all those instances of joe rogan
saying the n word
he was actually arguing against racism
right and they were taken out of context
to make him seem racist because sure
it's it you can so here's why i think
you know you mentioned we're in civil
strife i think it's civil war because
well that that's a technical threshold
like i i like it it's still it's
strictly terminology but we're
definitely seeing the normalization of
political violence i think we can agree
on that but uh i'm talking about fourth
and fifth generational war have you
researched any of those things well
not really so this is this is when uh uh
think about what the purpose of war is
right to gain control of an asset
resource land or a people
when you look at what started the first
civil war it was these military bases
and then eventually like preserving the
union gaining control and and holding
one government over the south because
they were trying to secede and form
their own country or whatever
what if you never had to fire a shot to
accomplish that well yeah fourth and
fifth generational warfare is when you
get into insurgency with fourth
generational and fifth generational is
manipulation and propaganda you mean
memetic warfare i mean the thing i find
pretty i'm i actually wrote about that
for foreign policy i i think it's a
really you know i actually think what's
happening in russia and ukraine not to
go off on a completely different thing
but i think it's one of the
earliest instances of truly memetic
warfare you know marshall mcluhan said
the third world war will be an
information war fought with no
distinction between civilians and
military and we're in it right like and
i think
and i think in that sense if you were to
think of the civil war as a memetic war
or as an informational wars or
diathetical war which is what lawrence
of arabia called it that you are
absolutely in it that's why i think when
we if we talk in terms of left and right
we've already lost the war because our
mind has been changed by the meme to
think in that way
well i think you know
there's like i think it's natural to
have a left and a right and i think it's
natural to have disagreement like i
don't i don't think you need to be in a
unified country to that that that's that
that's somehow better you have to feel
you're on the same team though it's true
that like yeah we'll have a left and
right but not to have two political
parties in control of a government
that's not natural i got informed on
purpose i want to read this one super
chat and make a point about many other
ones uh gold metro says thanks for
coming stephen you've been an
interesting voice on these matters but
understand for many you're asking them
to sacrifice all they feel is right and
honorable for the sake of peace with
those who hate them well would you
rather be married or right it's like
what i said right at the beginning it
was that's why i asked you about the
health care thing and you know i take
that point yeah like i genuinely do like
if someone were to ask me that if they
were like if that were the choices i
don't know what i would do there's a lot
of there's a lot of uh comments where
they're like you know this guy is wrong
and you know obviously but to the people
who got everyone's cup of tea no for
sure
and i knew uh uh having seen your
twitter yeah we had these disagreements
but i thought you know
like we try inviting many other people
of opposing views they don't come on the
show you can have me anytime oh i
thought it was fantastic conversation
and for the people the people who are
saying they don't want to buy your book
i think that is
that is very uh that is wrong i don't
think the thing i think this is the book
has stuff in it that is not me well i
think it should be i think you should i
think i genuinely think it's worth
reading look the president so i
understand if people are like i don't
want to buy his book because he doesn't
deserve my money or it'll make me rich
or whatever no no i think they should
read it because as i often say if you
think he's wrong wouldn't it be valuable
if they knew all of your thoughts and
ideas and research and where it came
from and then by all means you can take
the book we've actually had a couple
people commenting they did read your
book and felt you were wrong or whatever
right and that's the right answer you
know
almost 40 of the sources are republican
like i would just add like i don't think
these people like republicans right
i probably didn't help myself
yeah no but i mean um
i read cnn all the time and then i'm
like that one's wrong that was wrong and
then i read breitbart too and i'm like
that one's framed poorly and that one's
wrong
but like because you have to read
everything and then try and figure out
on a lot of articles it's tough so like
yes because when the new york times says
x is true i'm like
you just said something like how am i
supposed to know it's true just because
you said it
well as someone who's worked for a bunch
of publications i would say if something
is in new york times that is the that's
the most reliable news source of
anything i've worked for with the
possible exception of the atlantic when
you go to the new york times the
atlantic is fact when something's
fact-checked by the atlantic it is
fact-checked within an inch of its life
the the the new york times
i caught in
what i view as a major scandal of
publishing a news piece getting boosted
in the algorithm and altering it to an
op-ed for sustained growth and
they do it all the time right well
stealth editing but not other than that
i mean you look at what they did with
project veritas where they just lied
about them and then basically never
fact-checked it got sued even it was so
egregious that they've actually
surprisingly veritas has gotten past the
motion to dismiss which is crazy in
public definitely i thought the new york
times lost a lot of its credibility when
they published anonymous and they said
this was a high-level trump staffer with
intimate details of the trump
administration and then it turned out it
had like the same position i had in the
bush administration where you know you
have a job but but like their editorial
board their their senior leadership
allowed that to go forward saying this
is they made it look like it was a
cabinet position and they did it for
political expediency what did you guys
think of the palin trial
oh the dismissal yeah you know libel we
talked about that last time and libel is
is very hard i think times v sullivan
sullivan needs to be
removed are you familiar with what that
is yeah yeah yeah get rid of it
you really think so i mean it would make
you oh there you go i i thought it was i
thought it was fascinating that that um
someone took was the fall guy right that
that one editor said yeah this is on
james bennett the ultimate i mean
james bennett is a uh he's a fascinating
man because he's been in the middle of
these struggles and and
and
attacked by both sides i just don't
forget
you're being like absolutely superb like
you can mean the best op-ed editor i've
ever worked i just don't think the new
york times would ever allow such a piece
about about kamala harris oh i don't
know about that you could i i i would
not i would not
there's a lot of people let's wait and
see for those that are familiar times v
sullivan is the standard that basically
you have to prove
uh if defamation is of a public public
figure you have to prove that either
knew it was false or were acting
recklessly mo in malice well actual
malice actual mouse means that they uh
uh that they knew that they knew and
that they wanted to hurt this person no
no hurting is is
in canada it's completely different and
it's so it's a and it's so much easier
to sue somebody for
in the u.s actual malice doesn't refer
to um intention to cause harm
necessarily it's like it's that you knew
it was wrong and you didn't care yeah
that's right recklessness very hard to
prove and impossible unless you get pat
into discovery recklessness is that for
the new york times for instance if they
publish something you'd have to prove
that they didn't follow their standard
procedure for verification right and if
you can't get past a motion to dismiss
and you can't because of its own stan
it's it's insane you someone uh they
they outright make up stories about me i
can't i can't get into them because of
litigation and stuff like that but
they'll outright lie and make everything
up and then they're just like we assume
it to be true like we we we had a source
who said it therefore it's fact that you
should not be able to get away with that
and the anonymous source of stuff has
gotten out of control it's insane and
then not on top of that you have to
prove damages so what they did that's
easier to do no no no no no well you
could have palin could have done that so
with project veritas the new york times
argued they're uh they're so they their
their reputation is so tarnished you
can't possibly cause them damage
that's what happened with benedict
arnold's do you remember that's he was
sued for libel he won
and he said your but your reputation is
worth six six cents
that's what they gave him and they gave
him and they gave him wow yeah that was
like whatever you know hit the traitor
bennett arnold's right yeah again in the
revolutionary war he was like they were
like yeah you were slandered your
reputation is worth sixpence before he
left america all right afterwards so
i'll read uh we'll just read two more
because uh we've gone a bit long tonight
and i think it was worth it papa romano
says i disagree with him a lot but a
great guest
thank you uh people need like need to
understand we would we would have a lot
more guests that are more like
mainstream journalists and leftists if
they were willing to come on am i going
to become your pocket leftist no no
maybe the pocket canadian for sure
we need more canadian leftists dude
crossfire was one of the best shows of
all time newswise and we need that's
kind of what i want i will say
we have made a lot of money off people
not liking you
they're sending in super chats like he's
wrong i don't like it it's so good to
have someone from canada because your
perspective is invaluable for as for me
as an american i was grown in this
system so i need well i do think we like
you know we're as i say in the book
we're like horatio to your hamlet right
like we're the small irrelevant country
right on the edge we've like i've all
we've lived in i've lived in america i
have american friends i love america but
i'm not american
right like so i'm not part of this you
know america's not my mother right like
it's like when you say like with like
health care like that my blood goes up
with your stuff my blood does not go up
you see right so there's different
things that are important absolutely gun
control anything like that oh yeah
controls canada's like again it's really
odd because like nearly half of canadian
homes have a gun in it but it's not the
same gun culture at all right so there's
like
and it's certainly much much more
regulated and in canada cops kick in
people's doors and go into their houses
and arrest them and it's harder to do in
the united states though they do it for
sure well i mean i don't think we have
like
quite
canadian cops are incredibly non-violent
i mean that's part of the problem with
with ottawa like you know when when the
truckers came for paris they just sent
in the tear gas and it was all over in
half an hour
every day in france yeah i mean yeah and
like that's what would happen here
incidentally like if a trucker convoy
started and they went into chicago it
would not it would be over in a day yeah
like it would not it would not be like
canadian police being like let's try and
not hurt anybody but i mean we might get
to the end of this thing without well
occupy wall street is actually an
interesting counter example um but like
i i think if
you know if this thing ends without any
violence god willing um
it will be oddly a kind of national
achievement was there was there violence
from blm in canada there was a small
well it wasn't um
there were there were blm marches they
were much smaller yeah than than here um
there was a there were a series of um
indigenous uh movements that were uh
about about the about about about
pipelines but also about you know uh
historical genocide cultural genocide uh
they're burning down churches because of
wow um because of they were essentially
right-wing indigenous groups um well now
i would say national groups like they
why wouldn't they would not fall into
either category they're
they they're themselves right and so
they they they would i would not put
them i would support from the left
though
um i actually think they have a lot of
broad support like stephen harper who
was the first um
who was a last conservative prime
minister he was the first person to
acknowledge um crimes against uh in the
uh in the educational system and he
actually made a big he made a very
powerful statement about it i want to
just read one more because we've gone
long and we'll wrap it up but um
cowboyish says tim the guy has
demonstrated that he has bias why is it
wrong to give him our money to check for
ourselves
so i i think i wonder if this question
is shouldn't it be wrong right is that
what they mean or are they agreeing with
me i wanted to read that because my
point is
if
you only get news from one source
you'll have no idea what you're arguing
against
and then i remember i was working for a
greenpeace and i was outside of a
bookstore and i saw glenn beck's book
arguing against climate change and i was
like i should read that and i went i was
i think i was like 21 i went to the
bookstore and i started skimming through
it to see like some of it read a couple
chapters and i didn't buy the book i put
it back but i was like
buy my book don't read it if someone's
gonna make an argument and you're like i
completely disagree with this person
wouldn't you want to arm yourself with
the facts and data to properly be able
to argue your points and not only that i
don't think people should take
everything you've said here as
everything that's in the book and they
might oh no no no we barely touched on
we only touched on two chapters right
right i think people might read through
that and be like okay this one has less
to do with some of the stuff they talked
about because we have our bias on this
show but long story short
i understand them saying they don't want
to give you money
then i get but reading is not that much
money
it's like it's just a man's got to eat
also these kids
it's not like you're giving me the money
i just i just think uh i'm a proponent
of learning and reading as much as you
can and that's why like i'll watch cnn
and read some what they're writing and
be like when i come out and say hey this
story was wrong it's because i read the
story read about the author looked at
what they were researching and said
here's what they missed not because i i
saw the headline and went that's not
true bye and then to close out the
article now i got to read that stuff
otherwise i'm like i think reading in
itself is an act of depolarization yes
you know like i think actually
trying to understand people and trying
to be in their language for a bit yeah
is really is really helpful you know i
wrote this book explicitly trying not to
judge like you know you can say i'm part
but like i went and talked to all sorts
of people i wanted to get there like i
really would feel like i'd failed if i
didn't feel like the oath keepers that i
interviewed felt that they were
represented fairly like i i i am not
trying to skew anything right like i am
trying to even even people who i
consider outright criminals right like
i'm trying to get their point of view
and put it on the page and i think
that's that's key like if you want to if
you want to understand people you have
that's what you have to work towards
yeah you know all right i think we
should uh we should we should wind it
down here so uh go to timcast.com become
a member we're not going to do the
members segment because we decided just
to do this segment extra long to have
this deeper conversation and uh but but
becoming a member does help support all
of our work and there is a massive
library so there's tons of other
segments you can watch and it is greatly
appreciated when you sign up because
your membership sustains us you can
follow the show at tim cast irl on
instagram you can follow me at tim cast
as well don't forget to like this video
smash that smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share share
the show with your friends do you want
to shout out anything else your book
your social media just the book well i'm
stephen martial twitter if you want to
follow me but you know
but uh but they should they should tweet
at you the books oh please don't tell
them to tweet it
nice things don't do that to me like
six months from now you come back and
you're wearing a maga hat and you're
like
i learned i think i believe everything
they've said i was depolarized
or i was repolarized or i was just
really yeah you're wearing an american
flag yeah right yeah right on daniel yes
daniel turner power of the future it's
great to be here and i want to give a
shout out to our farm instagram page so
love your local gay uh sheep farmers
here in virginia bristol farm virginia
and it's called bristol farm because
that was the first hotel we ever stayed
at in vienna the bristol hotel so we
named our farm after that hotel and so
bristol farm virginia on instagram it's
new we're trying to get people because
we love small farms and we're trying to
connect with other small farmers now
everyone can agree with that yeah
like who can if you can't you agree with
that thank you local farming like
these these leftists they hate farm
animals i swear they just don't want to
eat these the way to depolarize is to
get the hell out of cities yeah and get
away from
you're not that wrong
make people raise it raise a couple
chickens together yes and have them
focus on the chicken's eyes and people
won't be so angry to to tweet and hate
and things like that if they have to
muck out stalls and clean and just
freshen up and get fresh eggs
yes thanks for coming in and doing the
top-down view that's really really
pleasure yeah
and maybe next time you're here we can
go a little higher and look from like a
hundred thousand feet
from we'll do cosmic next time okay
cosmic orders beautiful follow me ian
crossland.net i'll see you guys next
time thank you guys all very much for
tuning in i always love to have
conversations where we don't fully agree
on everything to me that's very much the
spice of life i appreciate you guys for
bearing with us and for sending us all
your crazy super chats you guys can
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlids thanks for hanging out
everybody become a member at timcast.com
and we will see you all tomorrow night
bye guys
you